data generated by companies and
individuals like us has grown massively
over the past decade as per statista.com
the global data are generated and
consumed would reach 181 zettabytes by
2025. organizations need to gather and
analyze such large volumes of data and
look at their past business performances
as well as results and use that
information to prepare for the future
that essentially is data analytics so
hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video tutorial of data analytics full
course 2022 by simply learn this video
will help you gain all the necessary
skills and knowledge within 12 hours to
become a data analyst in 2022. our
experienced trainers will take you
through the course but before we begin
if you love watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us so let's look at the topics we'll be
learning in this video
we'll start by understanding the basics
of data analytics and learn the top 10
data analyst skills for 2022. after that
we learned the top 10 data analysis
tools followed by looking at a use case
in Python
next you'll get an idea of how to
manipulate and visualize data using our
packages and then look at time series
analysis in our then we'll shift our
Focus to understanding data analytics
using Excel pivot tables and learn to
create Excel dashboards moving further
you'll see some interesting data
analytics projects related to
coronavirus Spotify World happiness
report and Olympics finally we will
learn some of the important questions
that are asked frequently in data
analytics interviews so let's get
started hi guys
welcome to another video tutorial by
simply loan in today's session
we will look at data analytics for
beginners
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to another mission update
in this video
we will discuss what data analytics is
and the need for data analytics
then we will look at the different ways
in which data analytics can be used
followed by the various steps involved
in the data analytics process
after that
we will get an idea about the different
tools used in data analytics and the
company is using data analytics
moving forward we will see a case study
on how Walmart uses data analytics for
better customer service and finally we
will perform a regression analysis in R
to predict sales based on the
advertising expenditure from three
mediums tv ads radio ads and newspaper
advertisements
so what is data analytics
companies around the world are
generating vast volumes of data every
hour this data could be in the form of
log files web server and transactional
data as well as various customer related
data also data has been generated at a
rapid rate from social media websites
and applications such as Facebook
Instagram Twitter and WhatsApp
companies want to use this data to
derive value out of it and make business
decisions
that's where data analytics comes into
use
data analytics is the process of
exploring and analyzing large data sets
to find hidden patterns unseen Trends
discover correlations and valuable
insights to make business predictions
data analytics improves the speed and
efficiency of your business
a few years ago a business would have
gathered information manually performed
statistical and complex analytics and
Unearthed information that could be used
for future decisions
but today that business can identify
insights on the Fly for immediate
decisions
most organizations have big data and
many understand the need to harness that
data and extract value out of it
so they use a lot of modern tools and
Technologies to perform data analytics
some of the tools I will discuss in
detail later in this tutorial
now that we have looked at what data
analytics really is let us understand
the ways in which you can use data
analytics
first is improved decision making
data analytics eliminates a lot of
guesswork and manual tasks from choosing
the right content planning marketing
campaigns and developing products
organizations can use the insights they
gain from data analytics to make
informed decisions leading to better
outcomes and customer satisfaction
it gives you a 360 degree view of your
customers which helps you understand the
behavior completely enabling you to
better meet their needs
second is better customer service
data analytics provides you with more
accurate insights of your customers
allowing you to tailor customer service
to their needs utilization and build
stronger relationships with them
your data can reveal information about
your customers communication preferences
their interests their concerns and more
it helps you give better recommendations
for products and services
next is efficient operations
data analytics can help you streamline
your processes save money and boost
production
when you have an improved understanding
of what your audience wants
you waste less time in creating ads and
content that don't match your audience
interests this helps you optimize your
campaigns create better content
strategies and hence improve results
and finally we have effective marketing
when you understand your audience better
you can Market to them more effectively
data analytics also gives you useful
insights into how your campaigns are
performing so that you can fine tune
them for optimal outcomes
you also find out the probable customers
who are the most likely to interact with
a campaign and convert into leads
now let's discuss the various steps
involved in the data analytics process
as you can see on the screen there are
five process steps now let me make you
understand each of this one by one
so the first step to understand the
problem
before starting with the analysis you
need to understand the business problem
and Define your goals
asking questions at the outlet is vital
because this would address issues such
as how can we reduce production costs
without sacrificing quality what are
some of the ways to increase sales
opportunities with our current resources
do customers view our brand in a
favorable way answers to these questions
will help you build a clear road map
with lucrative Solutions
also try to find processes data
collection
after you have final levels it's time to
start looking for your data data
collection is the process of gathering
information on targeted variables
identified as data requirements
the emphasis is on ensuring accurate and
right data is collected data collection
starts with primary sources which are
also known as internal sources this is
typically structured data gathered from
CRM software Erp systems marketing
automation tools and others these
sources contain information about
customers finances gaps in sales
Etc
under external sources you have both
structured and unstructured data so if
you are looking to perform a sentiment
analysis towards your brand you would
gather data from various review websites
or social media apps
the next step is to clean the data
the data which is collected from various
sources is highly likely to contain
incomplete duplicate and missing values
so you need to clean these unwanted
redundant data to make it ready for
analysis
so to generate accurate results
analytics professionals must identify
duplicate and anomalous data and other
inconsistencies that could skew the
analysis according to a report sixty
percent of data scientists say most of
the time is spent cleaning the data
while 57 percent of data scientists say
it's their least enjoyable task
now the fourth step in the process is
data exploration and Analysis
once data is cleaned and ready you can
go ahead and explore the data using data
visualization and business intelligence
tools
you can also use various Data Mining and
predictive modeling techniques to
analyze the data and build models
you can use different supervised and
unsupervised algorithms such as linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k n k-means clustering and lots
more to build prediction models for
making business decisions
and the final step is to interpret the
results
this part is important because it's how
a business will gain actual value from
the previous four steps
interpreting the results will help you
find unseen Trends and patterns in the
data and gain insights you can have a
validation check if the results are
answering your questions these results
can be shown to your clients and
stakeholders for better understanding
and business collaboration
now that we have looked at the various
steps involved in data analytics let's
now see the different tools that can be
used to perform the above steps
so as you can see we have seven tools
including a few programming languages
that will help you perform analytics
better now let's discuss them one by one
first we have python
python is an object-oriented open source
programming language that supports a
range of libraries for data manipulation
data visualization and data modeling
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via the python
package index which is pypi the
repository of python software
python provides the default package
installer called pip or pip
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas to
manipulate data on numerical tables and
time series then you have scipy for
Technical and scientific computations it
also provides scikit-learn which is a
machine learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it also has pi
torch and tensorflow for deep learning
up next we have r
R is an open source programming language
majorly used for numerical and
statistical analysis
it provides a range of libraries for
data analysis and visualization some of
these libraries are ggplot Thai DeVos
plotly deployer and carrot
then we have tableau
Tableau is a popular data visualization
and analytics tools that helps you
create a range of visualizations to
interactively present the data build
reports and dashboards to Showcase
insights and Trends it can connect with
multiple data sources and give hidden
business insights and patterns
then we have a competitor of Tableau
which is power bi
power bi is a business intelligence tool
developed by Microsoft that has an easy
drag and drop functionality and supports
multiple data sources with features that
make data visually appealing
power bi supports features that help you
ask questions to your data and get
immediate insights you can also forecast
your data for predicting future trends
so the next tool is Click View
click view provides interactive
analytics with in-memory storage
technology to analyze vast volumes of
data and use data discoveries to support
decision making
it provides social media Discovery and
interactive guided Analytics
it can manipulate huge data sets
instantly Apache spark is an open source
data analytics engine to process data in
real time and Carry Out complex
analytics using SQL queries and machine
learning algorithms
it supports spark streaming for
real-time analytics and Spark SQL for
writing SQL queries
it also has spark ml lib which is a
library that has a repository of machine
learning algorithms and then it has
graphics for graphical computation
and finally we have SAS
SAS is a statistical analysis software
and help you perform analytics visualize
your data write SQL queries perform
statistical analysis and build machine
learning models to make future
predictions SAS empowers our customers
to move the world forward by
transforming data into intelligence
SAS is investing a lot to drive software
Innovation for Analytics Gartner has
positioned SAS as a magic quadrant
leader for data science and machine
learning
moving on to the applications of data
analytics
first we have retail
customers expect retailers to understand
exactly what they need and when they
need it
data analytics helps retailers meet
those demands
retailers not only have an in-depth
understanding of their customers but
they can also predict Trends recommend
new preferences invoke the most relevant
engagement strategy for each customer
optimize supply chain and Retail
operations at every step of the customer
Journey
the second application is on Healthcare
Healthcare Industries analyze patient
data to provide life-saving diagnosis
and treatment options
they also deal with healthcare plans and
insurance information to drive key
insights using analytics they can
discover new drugs and come up with new
drug development methods
Advanced analytics allows healthcare
companies to improve patient outcomes
and experience
cancer cells and diabetic retinopathy
can be discovered using Medical Imaging
at number three we have Manufacturing
for manufacturers solving problem is
nothing new
they fight with difficult problems and
situations on a daily basis
from complex Supply chains to motion
applications to labor constraints and
Equipment breakdowns they deal with such
problems on a regular basis
using data analytics manufacturing
sectors can discover new cost saving and
revenue opportunities
the fourth application is related to the
banking sector
banking in finance collect vast volumes
of structured and unstructured data to
derive analytical insights and make
sound financial decisions
using analytics they can find out
probable loan defaulters customer
churnout rate and detect fraudulent
transactions immediately
the final application is based on
Logistics
logistics companies you data analytics
to develop new business models that can
ease their business and improve
productivity
they can optimize routes to ensure
delivery reaches on time in a cost
efficient manner improving order
processing capabilities as well as
Performance Management
with that
now let's look at the companies using
data analytics on a daily basis
so we have the e-commerce giant Amazon
then we have Accenture followed by the
American healthcare service organization
Cigna
then we have the American supplier of
Health Information Technology Solutions
Services devices and Hardware Cerner
followed by Target and Antivirus company
McAfee
next
we have Rapido which is an Indian bike a
Flipkart and the world's largest retail
company Walmart
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most basic questions that
you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight how many cells per call ratio
coming out of the call center if we have
500 tourists in a forest and you have a
certain temperature how many fires were
started how many times did the police
have to show up to certain houses all
happen next we want to predict this is
great if you have a ice cream store and
you want to predict how many people to
work at the ice cream store in a certain
day based on the temperature coming up
in the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive Analytics
how can we make it happen foresight what
can we change to make this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions uh
if we want to have our city generate
more income and we want that income to
be commercial based what kind of
commercial buildings do we need to build
in that area that are going to bring
people over do we need huge Warehouse
cells Costco sales buildings or do we
need little mom pod joints that are
going to bring in people from the
country to come shop there or do you
want an industrial setup what do you
need to bring that industry in there is
our car industry available in that area
if it's not a car industry what other
Industries are in that area all those
things are prescriptive we're guessing
we're guessing what can we do to fix it
what can we do to fix crime and area
with education what kind of education
are we going to use to help people
understand what's going on so that we
lower the rate of crime and we help our
communities grow better that's all
prescriptive it's all guessing we went
foresight into how can we make it happen
how can we make this better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager shareholder or the data
scientist coming in you really need to
understand the descriptive analytics
where you're studying the total units of
furniture sold and the profit that was
made in the past here we go into
Predictive Analytics predicting the
total units that would sell and the
profit we can expect in the future gear
up for how many employees we need how
much money we're going to make and
prescriptive analytics finding ways to
improve the sales and the profit so we
can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
hello everyone we welcome you all to
this video by simply learn in today's
session we will learn a really
interesting topic that is the top 10
skills to become a data analyst in 2022
in today's Digital World data is being
generated by companies and individuals
every second so the role of a data
analyst holds supreme importance
so if you're looking for a career in
data analytics this video will help you
learn what a data analyst does and the
various skills you need to possess to
become a data analyst in 2022
before we get started make sure you
subscribe to this simply launcher and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's look at the agenda for this video
first we will understand who a data
analyst is then we will understand the
top 10 data analyst skills for 2022.
moving on we will look at the salary of
a data analyst and finally we will look
at the companies hiring data analysts
so now let's understand who is the data
analyst
a data analyst is a professional who
collects business data from various
sources interprets it and uses various
statistical tools and techniques to and
useful information from it
they acquire data from primary or
secondary data sources and maintain
databases they also recognize and
understand the organization's goal and
collaborate with different team members
such as programmers business analysts
and data scientists to build an
effective solution to a business problem
now with this basic understanding of who
are data analyst is let's learn the top
10 data analyst skills for 2022.
at number one we have structured query
language or SQL SQL is a top skill that
every data analyst should have data
analysts use SQL commands and functions
to store process analyze and manipulate
structured data using relational and
nosql databases
they also build data models and write
complex SQL queries and scripts to
gather and extract information from
several databases and data warehouses
some of the popular databases a data
analysts should be familiar with are
Microsoft SQL Server MySQL postgresql
and IBM db2
the second important skill for a data
analyst is Microsoft Excel
my data data analysts need to know how
to handle tabular data in Excel so they
should be aware of features like sorting
filtering conditional formatting pivot
tables what-if analysis and functions
such as sumifs and countifs
the third crucial data analyst skill for
2022 is data cleaning and wrangling
usually the data collected by analysts
from various heterogeneous sources is
often messy and contains a lot of
missing values
so it is always crucial to killing or
erroneous elements
it is also important to format data
using tools and methods before using it
for analysis
they are responsible for data mining as
well
the data mined from various sources are
organized in order to obtain new
information from it some of the tools
you need to know for data cleaning and
wrangling are Excel power query and open
refine
the fourth skill on our list is
mathematics and statistics
data analysts often work on data for
higher Dimensions that are greater than
three in order to interpret such data
they need to be good at linear algebra
and calculus they also build predictive
models and statistical models such as
linear regression logistic regression
knife base and k-means clustering in
order to understand the working of these
algorithms they must have knowledge
about statistics and probability
coming to the fifth important skill for
a data analyst in 2022 we have
programming data analysts need to master
at least one programming language
preferably python or Raj in order to
work with complex business problems
analysts need to write scripts and
user-defined functions to automate
tedious tasks Python and R language
provide a collection of different
libraries and packages such as numpy
pandas deeply matplotlib ggplot which
data analysts can use to discover Trends
and patterns from complex data sets
after this we have data visualization as
a sixth skill another data analyst job
role is to visualize large volumes of
data and prepare summary reports and
dashboards for the leadership team and
clients so that they can make timely
business decisions
to do this data analysts use various
data visualization tools such as power
bi Tableau and click View
using these tools data analysts can
integrate various data sets apply joint
conditions sort and filter data as well
create different visualizations using
charts and graphs
the seventh skill for a data analyst is
industry knowledge
data analysts should have good knowledge
and understanding of the industry or
domain they are working in for example
if you're working in a healthcare domain
you need to know how Healthcare
analytics can be applied to improve
patient care you should have knowledge
about the challenges faced in healthcare
and how you can leverage data and
analytics to solve the issues only if
you have strong industry knowledge can
you try to improve the business
the eighth skill that is important for a
data analyst in 2022 data analysts
should be ready to face those challenges
data analysts are expected to use their
problem solving skills work with the
team troubleshoot what went wrong and
provide an effective solution via data
analysis
a data analyst with good problem solving
skills can help a business identify
current and potential issues and
determine a viable solution based on the
data it collects
the ninth scale on our list is
analytical thinking
data analysts need analytical thinking
ability to break down a complex problem
into simple components and resolve these
components one by one
it is a must-have skill for data
analysts
analytical thinking includes deciding
the parameters that need to be
considered for defining data sets
analyzing them from different
perspectives and determining variable
dependencies
coming to the 10th skill among the top
10 skills for a data analyst in 2022 we
have communication
data analysts don't just interact with
computers and programs they also
interact with team members stakeholders
and data suppliers
so good communication skills are
essential
data analysts also present their
findings in front of an audience who
might not be familiar with the
analytical methods and processes so they
need to clearly translate their findings
and insights into non-technical terms so
those were the top 10 skills our data
analyst needs to possess in 2022 do you
think we missed out on any skills then
please put your answers in the comment
section below
now let's look at the salary of a data
analyst
according to Glassdoor the average
annual salary for a data analyst in the
United States is 69
517 dollars while in India you can earn
nearly 7 lakh rupees per random
finally let's look at the top companies
that are hiring data analysts in 2022.
here we have the consultancy and big4
giant Deloitte and the pharmaceutical
company Cerner Corporation then we have
the tech giant IBM retail company
Walmart and the e-commerce leader Amazon
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data who should you
learn if you want to make a career in
this field we will answer that in this
session after extensive research we have
come up with these top 10 data analysis
tools here we will look at the features
of each of these tools and the companies
using them so let's start off
at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel all
of us would have used Microsoft Excel at
some point right it is easy to use and
one of the best tools for data analysis
developed by Microsoft Excel is
basically a spreadsheet program using
Excel you can create grids of numbers
text and formulas it is one of the
widely used tools be it in a small or
flat setup
the interface of Microsoft Excel looks
like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly Excel works with
the windows version of excel supports
programming through Microsoft's Visual
Basic for applications VBA
programming with VBA allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
data organization in VBA
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts by doing so it's a lot easier
to analyze data especially while
creating graphs and other visual data
representations the visualization can be
generated from specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
Microsoft Excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use Excel fit them that use it for
analysis are the UK based company Ernest
and Young then we have Urban Pro Wipro
and Amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number nine we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
Commercial sector rapidminer also
supports all the steps of the machine
learning process
seen on your screens is the interface or
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop it is very convenient to just
drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation and Analysis
task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer we have the Caribbean
Airline Leeward Islands Air transport
next we have the United Health Group the
American online payment company PayPal
and the Austrian Telecom company
MobileComm so that was all about
rapidminer now let's see which tool we
have at number
we have talent at number
Talent is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in Big
Data integration Talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and Big Data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the great
bones Talent offers it even maintains
the tasks for the users this helps with
quick deployment and development
it also offers open source tools Talent
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the process is
gradually speed up
Talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases SAS and other Technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and Cloud apps 10
times faster
those were the features of the companies
using Talent are Air France L'Oreal cab
Gemini and the American multinational
Pisa restaurant chain Domino's
next on the list we have nine
Constance information minor on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept nime
has been used in pharmaceutical research
and other areas like CRM customer data
analysis business intelligence text
Mining and financial data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the nine features
9 provides an interactive graphical user
interface to create visual workflows
using the drag and drop feature use of
gdbc allows assembly of nodes blending
different data sources including
pre-processing such as ETL that is
extraction transformation loading for
modeling data analysis and visualization
with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing 9 allows users to
visually create data flows selectively
execute some or all analysis steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
9 server automates workflow execution
and supports team-based collaboration
nime integrates various other open
source projects such as machine learning
algorithms from Becca H2O Caris Park and
our project
nime allows analysis of 300 million
custom addresses 20 million cell images
and 10 million molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are United Health Group asml fractal
analytics atos and LEGO Group let's now
move on to the next tool we have SAS at
number six
SAS facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in SAS data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of SAS
using SAS better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation as our SQL
SAS allows you to access through
Microsoft Office by letting you create
reports using it and by Distributing
them through it
SAS helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using SAS we have companies like genpact
iqria Accenture and IBM to name a few
that was all about SAS
so for all those who joined in late let
me just quickly repeat our list at
number 10 we have Microsoft Excel then
at number nine we have rapidminer at
number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine and at number six we
have SAS so far you'll agree with this
list let us know in the comment section
below let's now move on to the next five
Tools in our list
so at number five we have both R and
python yes we have two of them in the
fifth position
R is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well it has
traditionally been used in academics and
research python is a high level
programming language which has a python
data analysis Library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from Excel spreadsheets to processing
them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the Python
Jupiter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both R and python
when it comes to the availability of R
and python it is very easy both are in
Python are completely free hence it can
be used without any license
I used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both are in
Python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both R and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using R we
have Uber Google Facebook to name a few
python is used by many companies again
to name a few we have Amazon Google and
the American photo and video sharing
social networking service Instagram
that was all about R in Python
at number four we have Apache Spark
Apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
Analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources including Hadoop
distributed file system htfs openstack
Swift Amazon S3 and Cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs
Apache spark is designed to accelerate
analytics on Hadoop while providing a
complete Suite of complementary tools
that include a fully featured machine
learning library a graph processing
engine and stream processing
so this is how the interface of Apache
spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of Apache Spark
spark stores data in the ram hence it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics spark
helps to run an application in a Hadoop
cluster up to 100 times faster in memory
and 10 times faster when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in Java Scala r or python
spark comes up with 80 high-level
operators for interactive querying spark
code for batch processing joint stream
against historical data or run ad hoc
queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
spark has a rich set of SQL queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics Etc Apache spark provides
fault tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero
Lockheed Martin and eBay are some of the
companies that use Apache spark on a
daily basis
at number 3 we have another important
growing data analysis tool that is Click
View
click view software is a product of
Click for business intelligence and data
visualization click view is a business
Discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations
with click view you can analyze data and
use your data discoveries to support
decision making
clickview is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
Gartner magic quadrant
on the screen you can see how the
interface of Click view looks like
now talking about its features
clickview provides interactive guided
analytics with in-memory storage
technology during the process of data
Discovery and interpretation of
collected data the clickview software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations
clickview uses a new patent in memory
architecture for data storage all the
data from the different sources is
loaded in the ram of the system and it
is ready to be retrieved from there
it has the capability of efficient
social and mobile data discovery
social data Discovery offers to share
individual Data Insights within groups
or out of it
a user can add annotations as an
addition to someone else's insights on a
particular data report clickview
supports mobile data Discovery within an
HTML file enabled touch feature which
lets the user search the data and
conduct data Discovery interactively and
explore other server-based applications
click view performs olap and ETL
features to perform analytical
operations extract data from multiple
sources transform it for usage and load
it to a data warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career and click view are
Mercedes-Benz cab Gemini Citibank
constant and Accenture to name a few
at number two we have power bi
power bi analytics solution that lets
you visualize your data and share
insights across your organization or
embed them in your app a website
it can connect to hundreds of data
sources and bring your data to life with
live dashboards and reports
power bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations collate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources through a user-friendly
interface
power bi is built on the foundation of
Microsoft Excel and has several
components such as stop application
called Power bi desktop and online
software resist service called Power bi
service mobile power bi apps available
on Windows phones and tablets as well as
for IOS and Android devices
here is how the power bi interface looks
like as you can see there is a visually
interactive sales report with different
charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi
it has an easy drag and drop
functionality with features that make
data visually appealing you can create
reports without having the knowledge of
any programming language power bi helps
users see not only what's happened in
the past and what's happening in the
present but also what might happen in
the future
it offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards you can select
several charts and graphs from the
visualization pane power bi has machine
learning capabilities with which it can
spot patterns in data and use those
patterns to make informed predictions
and run what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as Excel Tech CSV Oracle SQL Server
PDF and XML files the platform
integrates with other popular business
management tools like SharePoint Office
365 and Dynamics 365 as well as other
non-microsoft products like spark Hadoop
Google analytics sap Salesforce and
MailChimp
some of the companies using power bir
Adobe AXA Carlsberg capture menai and
Nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
Gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified Tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
Tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in Jan 2003
in Mountain View California
Tableau is a data visualization software
that is used for data science and
business intelligence it can create a
wide range of different visualization to
interactively present the data and
showcase insights
the important products of Tableau are
Tableau desktop Tableau public Tableau
server Tableau online and Tableau reader
this is how the interface of Tableau
desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with Tableau
and the visualizations created are in
the form of dashboards and worksheets
Tableau delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on the Fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data writing simple SQL queries
can help join multiple data sets and
then build reports out of it you can
create transparent filters parameters
and highlighters
Tableau allows you to ask questions spot
Trends and identify opportunities with
the help of Tableau online you can
connect with Cloud databases Amazon
redshift and Google bigquery
the company is using Tableau are
Deloitte Adobe Cisco LinkedIn and the
American e-commerce giant Amazon to name
a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools since this is data
analysis with python
we got to ask the question why python
for data analytics I mean they're C plus
there's Java there's dot net from
Microsoft why do people go to python for
it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high type set like
you do in Java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of be a little lazy
in your programming that doesn't mean
that it can't be set that way and that
you don't have to be careful it just
makes means you can spin up a code much
quicker in Python the same amount of
code to do something in Python A lot of
times is one two or three or four lines
where when I did the same thing say in
Java I found myself a 10 12 13 20 lines
depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible so
there's our flexibility because you can
do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine to using a pi spark under
the spark environment and spread that
across hundreds if not thousands of
servers across terabytes of data or
petabytes of data so it's very scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
Java has a huge collection of libraries
C has a huge collection of
libraries.net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
Scala for your spark all those have huge
collection of libraries this is always
changing but because Python's open
source you almost always have easy to
access libraries that anybody can use
you don't have to go check your
licensing and have special licensing
like you do in some packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick Google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics and the big five
players are numpy pandas matplot Library
scipy which is going to be in the
background so we're not going to talk
too much about the scientific formulas
inside pi and PSY kit
so numpy supports in dimensional arrays
provides numerical Computing tools
useful for linear algebra and Fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers and you can even have a grid
inside a grid or data it's not even
numbers because you can also put words
and characters and just about anything
into that array but you can think of a
grid and then you can have a grid inside
a grid and you end up with a nice
three-dimensional array
if you want to talk three-dimensional
array you can think of images you have
your three channels of color four if you
have an alpha and then you have your X Y
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine watching a
movie well now you have your movie clips
and they each have their X number of
frames and each of those frames have X
number of X Y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors so
numpy is just a great way to work within
dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas useful
for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame and if you're
working with big data and you're working
in spark or any of the other major
packages out there you realize that the
data frame is very Central to a lot of
that and you can look at it as a Excel
spreadsheet you have your columns you
have your rows or indexes and you can do
all kinds of different manipulations of
the data within including filling in
missing data which is a big thing when
you're dealing with large pools or lakes
of data where they might be collected
differently from different locations
and matplot Library
we did kick over the sci Pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
for of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matplot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in Python several
toolkits extend matplot Library
functionality there's like a hundred
different toolkits to extend matplot
Library which range from how to properly
display star constellations from
astronomy there's a very specific one
built just for that all the way to some
very generic ones we'll actually add
Seaborn in when we do the labs in a
minute several tool kits extend matplot
Library functionality and it creates
interactive visualization so there's all
kinds of cool things you can do as far
as just displaying graphs and there's
even some that you can create
interactive graphs we won't do the
interactive graphs but you'll see you'll
get a pretty good grasp of some of the
different things you can do in matplot
library
let's jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves get our
hands in on what we're doing now there's
a lot of options when we're dealing with
python you can use pie charm as a really
popular one
and you'll see this all over the place
so it's one of the main ones that's out
there and there's a lot of other ones to
use netbeans which is kind of lost favor
don't even have it installed on my new
computer
but the most popular one right now for
data science Now pycharm is really
popular for python General development
for data science we usually go to
Jupiter notebook or anaconda and we're
going to jump into Anaconda because
that's my favorite one to go to because
it has a lot of external tools for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like so with Anaconda we have our
Jupiter lab we have our notebook these
are identical Jupiter lab is an upgrade
to the notebooks with multiple tabs
that's all it is and we'll be using the
notebook and you can see that pycharm is
so popular with python that we even have
it highlighted here in Anaconda as part
of the setup
uh Jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone so we're actually going to be
running Jupiter notebook and then you
have your different environments I have
we're going to be under main Pi 36
there's a root one and I usually label
it Pi 3 6. the reason is is currently as
of writing this tensorflow only works in
3 6 and not in three seven or three
eight for doing neural networks but you
can actually have multiple environments
which is nice they're they separate the
kernel so it helps protect your computer
when you're doing development and this
is just a great way to do a display or a
demo especially if you're looking for
that job pull up your laptop open it up
or if you're doing a meeting get a
broadcast up to the big screen so that
the CEO can see what you're looking at
and when we launched the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be Chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending what you have installed
python3 and this just creates an
Untitled version of this and you can see
here I'm actually in a simply learned
folder for other work I've done for
simply learn
and that's where I save all my stuff and
I can browse through other folders
making it really easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics data analytics just so I
can remember what I was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right now uh so let's go ahead and jump
in there and take a look at some of
these different tools that we were
looking at
and as we go through the demo let's
start with the numpy uh the least
visually exciting and I'm going to zoom
in here so you can see what we're doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as NP that is the
most common numpy terminology
and let's go ahead and change the view
so we also have the line numbers I don't
know why we probably won't need them but
I like it for easy reference and then
we'll create a one dimensional array we
just call this array one
and it equals NP dot array and you put
your array information in here in this
case we'll spell it out you can actually
do like a range in other ways there's
lots of ways to generate these arrays
but we'll just do one two three so three
integers
and if we print
our array one
we can go ahead and run this
and you can see right here it prints one
two three you can see why this is a
really nice interface to show other
people what you're doing with the
jupyter notebook
so this is the basic we've created an
array this is a one dimensional array
and then the array is one two three one
of the nice things about the Jupiter
notebook is whatever ran in this first
setup
is still running it's still in the
kernel so it still has the numpy
imported as in p and it still has our
variable
arr1 for array 1 equal to NP array of
one two three
so we go to the next cell
we can check the type of the array we're
just going to print
we say hey what's what what is this
setup in here and we want type
and then we want what is the type of
array one let's go ahead and run that
and it says class numpy ND array so it's
its own class that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class
probably the biggest thing you do I
don't know how many times I find myself
doing this because I forget what I'm
working on and I forget I'm working with
a three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array and I have to reformat somehow so
it works with whatever other things I
have and so we do the array shape the
ray shape is just three because it has
three members and it's a one-dimensional
array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access stick with the print statement
if you actually put a variable in
Jupiter notebook and it's the last one
in the cell
it will the same as a print statement so
if I do this where array one of two it's
the same as doing print
array of two that's those are identical
statements in our jupyter notebook
we'll go and stick with the print on
this one
and it's three so there's our print
space two and we have 0 1 2
2 equals 3 we can easily change that so
we have array one of place two
equals five
and then if we print our array one
you can see right down here when it
comes out it's one two and five
and there I left the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list it'll always print the variable if
you just put it in like that
that's a Jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pi charm I've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple Dimensions
so we'll do an array two-dimensional
array and this is again a numpy array
and in the numpy array
we need our first Dimension we'll do one
two three
and our
second dimension three four five and you
can see right here that when we hit the
uh we'll do this we'll just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four five
we can also do array two
of 1
and then we can do let's do a zero it
doesn't really matter which one actually
let's do uh two there we go and if I run
this it'll print out five uh because
here we are this is zero uh zero one two
three is under zero Row three four five
is on our one row now we start with zero
and then the two zero one two goes to
the five
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we'll go do array two
dot shape
and if we do array 2 of shape
we'll go and run that we'll see we have
two rows and each row has three elements
a two-dimensional array two three if you
looked up here when we did it before it
just had three comma nothing when you
have a single entity it always saves it
as a tuple with a blank space
but you can see right here we have two
comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array two of oh let's go what
is it one
comma 2
we run that we get the five you can also
count backwards this is kind of fun
and you'll see I just kind of switch
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot
now two is the last
one zero one two it's the last one in
there we can count backwards and do
minus one and if we run this we get the
same answer whether we count it as uh
let's go back up here whether we count
this as 0 1 2
or we count backwards as minus one minus
two minus three and you can see that if
I change this minus one to a minus two
and run that
I get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus two so there's a lot of different
ways to reference what we're working on
inside the numpy array
it's really a cool tool it's got a lot
of things you can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not values and
we'll call this array s for Strings
equals NP dot array
put our setup in there brackets and
let's go
China
um
India
USA
Mexico doesn't matter we can make
whatever we want on here and if we print
that out
we run this you can see that we get our
numpy array China India USA Mexico it
even gives us our D type of a U6
and a lot of times when you're messing
with data we'll call this array R for
range
just to kind of keep it uniform NP dot a
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data Maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do integers
and we're going to do a setup from 0 to
20 skipping every other one
and we'll print it out and see what that
looks like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18. like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here uh why well this
starts at zero and counts up to 20. so
if you're used to another language where
explicitly says less than or less than
equal to 20 like for x equals zero X
plus plus X is less than 20. that's what
this is it just assumes X is less than
20 on here
and if we want to create a very uniform
uh set you know zero two four six what
happens if I want to create numbers uh
from 0 to 10 but I need 20 increments in
there we can do that with line space so
we can create an R we'll call this l
equals I don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so I don't know why
I'm creating unique identifiers for it
but we'll do NP
Lin space
and we're going to do 0
to 10 or 0 to 9. remember it doesn't it
goes up to 10. and then we want to let's
say we have 20
different
um
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20 and it
happens to just have 10 pieces in it and
here we go you can see right here we
have 20 or has 20 pieces in it but it's
over 10 years and we got to divide it in
the middle and you can see it does it
goes 0.52 remember the others are 10 on
the end so it goes up to 10.
uh and then we can also do random
there's NP dot random if you're doing
neural networks usually you start it by
seeding it with random numbers
and we'll just do NP dot random and
we'll just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it
and you can see we have random numbers
they are zero to one so you'll see that
all these numbers are under one and you
can easily alter that by multiplying
them out or something like that if you
want to do like zero to a hundred you
can also round them up if it's integer 0
to 100 there's all kinds of things you
can do but generates a random float
between zero and one
and you have a couple options you could
reshape that or you can just generate
them in whatever shape you want and so
we can see here we did three and four
and so you can see three rows by four
variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to three and four
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set I have had this
come up many times where I need to start
off with zero and I don't know you know
because I'm going to be adding stuff in
there or it might be 0 and 1 or 1 is if
you're moving around of an image you
might want the background is zero and
then you figure out where the image is
and you set all those boxes to one and
you create a mask so creating masks over
images is really big and doing that with
a numpy array of zero
and we can also uh
give it a space
and we'll just do this all in one shot
this time
and we'll do the same thing like we did
before
zeros and in this case we'll do a two
comma three
and so we run this
forgot the asterisks around it I knew I
was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this you can see here we
have our 10 zeros in a row and maybe
this is a mask for an image and so it
has uh two rows of three digits in it so
it's a very small image a little tiny
pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way instead of creating a
mask of zeros and filling in with ones
maybe you want to create a mask of ones
and fill them in with zeros and we'll
just do just like we did before with the
three comma four and when we run this
you'll see it's all ones and we could
even do this even we'll do it this way
let's do
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors and you can so creates
quite a large array there for doing
pictures and stuff like that when you
add that third dimension in
um if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
and you can also do something like
create an array
and then we'll do 0 1 2
and then in this array we actually print
right out we want a repeat and so you
can actually do a repeat of the array
and maybe you need this array
let's repeat it three times
so there's our repeat of an array repeat
three times
and if we run this
you'll see we have zero zero zero one
one two two two
and whenever I think of a repeat I don't
really think of repeating being the
first digit three times the second digit
I really always think of it as zero one
two zero one two zero one two it catches
me every time but the actual code for
that one is going to be tile and again
if we do a range three
and we run this you can see how you can
generate one zero one two zero one two
zero one two
if you're dealing with an identity
Matrix we can do that also if you're big
on you're doing your matrixes and we'll
just identity
I guess we'll go ahead and spell it out
today any tricks
and the command we're looking for is um
i e y e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity Matrix
and it comes out by a three by three
array because there's our Matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
Matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too
we talk about
matrixes
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have the diagonal
so we can do an NP dot diagonal
then we do a diagonal let's put in the
diagonal
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there's the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array and
you can see it generates a diagonal one
two three four five and there's your uh
your beginning of your Matrix array for
working with matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse let's
create an array equals remember our
random
random.random and we'll do a five by
five array oops there we go
five five
and just so you can see what that looks
like
helps if I don't mistype the numbers
which in this case I just need to take
out the brackets and there you go you
have your your five by five array set up
in there and we can know because we're
working with matrixes we might want to
do this in reverse and extract the
diagonals which would be the 0.79 the
0.678 and so on
and we simply type in NP dot diagonal
and we put our array in there
and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our Matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do print the shape
out you can also do the dimensions so in
Dimensions very similar to shape it
comes out and just has two Dimensions we
can also look at the size so if we do
size on here we can run that and you can
see as a size of 25 two dimensions and
of course five by five and that was from
the shape from earlier that we looked at
there's our five by five shape
and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do uh random I
talked a little bit about manipulating 0
to 1 and how you can get different
answers you can also do straight for the
integer part and we'll do minus 10.
and so we're going to Generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10 we're
going to generate four of those so when
we run that we have 7 minus 3 minus six
minus three they're all be between minus
10 and 10 and there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays which is really
great because this is where they come in
here's the array and you can add 10 to
it and if I run this there takes my
original array from up here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have oh this is
the decimal that's right this is a
random decimal I had stored in Array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers I had from 0 to 1 and
adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do uh
minus 10
. we could even do
times two
and we could do divide by two
and it would it'll take that random
number we generated and cut in half so
now all these numbers are under 0.5
another way you can
change the numbers to what you need on
there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential so as an exponential
function which would generate some
interesting numbers off of the random
so we're taking them to the power I
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the um array were because we
did the random numbers up there here's
our original numbers and if you build an
exponential on there uh this is where
you get e to the X on this and just like
you can do e to the X you can also do
the log so if you're doing logarithmic
functions
that reinforced learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic of these
different array numbers
and if you're working with a log base 2
you can do you can just change it in
there in P log 2. you have to look it up
because this is not log one two three
four five it is Log and log 2. so just a
quick note that's not a variable going
in that is an actual command there's a
number of them in there and you'll have
to go look and see what the
documentation is but you can also do log
10. so here's log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your sign
so we can take a sine value of all of
our different values in there
and if you have sine you of course have
cosine
we can run that
so here's the cosine of those and if
you're doing activations in your lumpy
array and you're doing a tangent
activation there's your tangent for that
and the tangent activation is actually
from neural networks that's one of the
ways you can activate it because it
forms a nice curve between from whether
you're generating 1 to negative one with
some discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into it we just put the
array back out there so we can see it uh
when we're doing this
as we're getting into this you can also
sum the values so we have NP sum
and you can do a summation of all the
values in this array and you'll see that
if you added all these together they'd
equal
12.519 and so on I don't know what the
whole setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this one of the things you
can also do is buy axes so we could do
axes equals zero
and if we run the summation of the axes
equals zero
and you can think of that in numpy as
the rows so that would be or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one
and now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to um
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal now you're looking
for and this comes up a lot because you
have like your errors we want to find
the minimal error inside of this array
and just like the other one we can do
axes equals zero
and you can see here
0.0645 is the smallest number in this
First Column is 0.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit and here
we go you can see maximum 0.79 is a
maximum on this first column and just
like we did before you can change this
to a one
on axes you can take the axes out of
here and just find the max value for the
whole array and the max value in here
was 0.8344 so on so on
and since we're talking data analytics
we want to go ahead and look at the mean
pretty much the same as the average this
is the mean across the whole thing and
just like we did before we could also do
axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axis and so on
and we have mean we might want to know
the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers if we have median we might want
to know the standard deviation or if we
have the average a lot of times you do
the means and the standard deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axes we can also do
it across the whole array
if we're going to do standard deviations
there's also variance
which is your VAR
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means there's more
but those are the most common ones used
with data analytics and then going
through your data and figuring out what
you're going to present to the
shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices you'll hear
that terminology
and a slice might be like we have a five
by five array but maybe we don't want
the whole array maybe we want uh from
one on we don't want the zero in there
so we got up to four and maybe on the
second part we just want
to
to row three and see this notation right
here says one to the end and if we run
this you can see how that generates a
single row to the end and then row two
and three now remember it doesn't
include three that's why we only get the
one column so if we wanted two and three
you would need to go ahead and go two to
four so it goes up to four we could also
do this in reverse
just like we learned earlier we can go
minus one oops
and when we go to minus one
it's the same thing because we have zero
one two three four this is the same
thing as two to four it goes two to the
last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here that we randomly
generated and we might want to um
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there uh
axis equals one if we run this you can
see from the axis that it sorts it
the point two being the lowest value to
the highest value by the row we can also
change this of course to axis zero if
you're sorting it by columns so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array
and we can sort that I don't usually do
that but you know I guess sometimes you
might that might come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
uh something now let's just go ahead and
reprint our array so we can look at it
again starting to get too many boxes up
there uh something else you can do with
an array
is we can take and transpose it this
comes up more than you would think when
you transpose it you'll see that the
rows and the column are transposed so
where
0.79.57 0.064 is a column now we've
switched it and we have
0.79.42 as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple
and then we'll just do all the other the
full rows and if we run this you can see
how it comes up a little bit different
and we'll just do the same slice up here
so you can see how those two look next
to each other
there we go there's our slice run
and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has a one two three four five
columns now we have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this together was a
function so the original version was
transpose and this still works you can
still see it generates the same value as
just a capital T so many times we flip
this data because we'll have an X Y
value or we'll have an image or
something like that and it's being read
one way into the next process and the
next one needs it the opposite so this
actually happens a lot you need to know
how to transpose the data really quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
um here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening why would you flatten your
data if this is an array going into a
neural network
you might want to send it in as one set
of values instead of two rows and you
can see here is all the values as a
single array it just flattens it down
into one array
so we covered our scientific means
transpose median some different
variations on here some of the other
things we want to do is what happens if
we want to append to our array so let's
create a new array
you're getting tired of looking at the
same set of random numbers we generated
earlier
so we'll go ahead and create a new array
here something a little simpler so it's
easier to see what we're doing
and four five six seven eight
that's good enough we'll just do four
five six seven eight
and if we print this array
there it is four five six seven eight
and we might want to append something to
the array so we have our array we need
to extend it you got to be very careful
about appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for that
one is runtime because of the way the
numpy ray is set up a lot of times you
build your data and then push it into
the numpy array instead of continually
adding on to the array
and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy for
protecting your data so there's a lot of
reasons to be careful about appending
this way but you can certainly do it and
we can just take our array we're going
to create a new array array one
and if we print array 1 and we append 8
to it you'll see four five six seven and
then there's our 8 appended on to the
end
and if you want to append something to
an array you'd probably also want to
whoops
array one let's try that again there we
go now we have the eight appended on to
the end
so you can see four five six seven eight
and then we pinned it another eight on
there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to go ahead and insert
instead of appending it might be you
need to keep a certain order and we can
do the same thing we do our array
um and we're going to pin or insert at
the beginning and let's go ahead and
insert uh one two three one two three
and we go ahead and print our array two
we run it and you can see one two three
append is inserted at the beginning
uh inserts a lot more powerful and that
you can put it anywhere in the array we
can move it to the one spot and there we
go one two three we can do a minus one
just for fun and you'll see it comes up
one two three and we're counting
backwards by one
I imagine you can do minus zero
and run this and it turns out that -0
puts it back at the beginning because
that's why it registers a zero just
takes a minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers and so let's do
an NP dot delete well let's let's keep
it a little bit make it a little easy
here to watch we'll go ahead and create
an array three
and we'll do NP delete we're just
working with array 2
and we want to do is delete zero space
so if we look at this here's our array 2
our rate 2 starts with one and when we
delete the space on here
and print that out we deleted the one
right out of there
and we can also do something like this
where we can do it as a slice and we can
do let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma 3 you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with adding lines and deleting lines
you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved as far
as where the data is coming from and
it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it so there's always a warning when we
talk about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
we'll create a array C which equals
we'll just do our our numpy array that
we just created our Olympia array 3 and
we can do copy so you can make a copy of
it maybe you want to protect your
original data or maybe you're making a
mask and so you copy the array and then
the new array make all these alterations
and change it from values to zero to one
to mask over the first one and of course
we if we do array C since it equals a
copy of array three it's the same thing
one three five six seven eight
and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays
I end up doing a lot of this
and I don't know how many times I end up
fiddling with this and having a mess
so but but you do it a lot you know you
combine your raise you split them you
might need one set of data for one thing
another set of data for the other
so let's go and create two arrays array
one array two
and I want you to note
and the terminology we're going to look
for is concatenate what that means is
we're going to take
um we'll call this a ray cat I like a
ray cat there we go our array cat our
concatenated array
we're taking array one and two
and it's very important to really pay
attention to your axes and your counts I
can't merge two arrays that have like
the if their axes are messed up and I'm
merging on axis zero it's going to give
me an error and I'll have to reshape
them so you got to make sure that
whatever you're concatenating together
works
and what that means
as you can see here we have one two
three four one two three four and then
five six seven eight five six seven
eight along the zero axis
these each are four values
um so it's a two by four value and if we
go ahead and switch this to one you can
see how that's that flips it a little
bit so now we have one two three four
five six seven eight
it's interesting that we chose that one
if I did something like this
where this is now
there we go and we concatenate it we run
this and it gives me an answer okay
because I have two by two and I'm using
axes one but if I switch this to axis 0
where now it's got three and five
it gives me an error so you got to be
really careful on that to make sure that
your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match so like I said
this one oops X is one axis one has two
entities and since we're going on axis
one or by row you can see that it lets
it merge it right onto the end there
and you could imagine this if this was a
x y plot of value or the x value going
in and the predicted y value coming out
and then you have another prediction and
you want to combine them this works
really easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops I forgot how many changes I made
there we go I'll just put it whoops I
messed up in my concatenation order here
[Music]
there we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation axes is
really important when you're doing your
concatenation values on here
and we'll switch us back to one just
because I like the looks of that better
there we go two rows
now there are other commands in here
um so we can do cat V
equals npv v stack
this is nothing more than your
concatenation
um but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there because it's v stands for
vertical
and so if we print out
cat
V and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack
and if you're going to have a vertical
stack you can also have an H stack
so if we change this to from v stack to
oops here we go H stack and we'll just
change this from cat to cat
and I run this
it's the same as doing axis zero the
process is identical in the background
this is like a legacy setup your v-stack
and your H stack most people just use
concatenate and then put the axes in
there because it's much has a lot more
clarity and is more more commonly used
nowadays
the last section in numpy we're going to
cover is
is kind of a data exploration and
that'll make a little bit more sense in
just a moment sometimes they call them
set operations but let's say we have an
array one two three four five six three
whatever it is I think so we generate a
natural array here and what I want to go
ahead and do is find the unique values
in that array
so maybe I'm generating what they call a
one hot encoder and so these values then
all become I need to know how long my
bit Ray is going to be so each word how
many how many each word is represented
by a number and then I want to know just
how many of those words are in there if
we're doing word count very popular
thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
we have one two three four five six
those are our unique values
some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just unique we can do uniques
our unique values and counts of each
unique value
and this is very similar to we just did
up here where we we're doing NP unique
but we're going to add a little bit more
into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts equals
true so instead of just returning the
unique values we want to know how many
of those unique values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print
our uniques
and print
our counts
let me run that you can see here we have
our unique value one two three four five
six just like we had before and then
there's two of the first of two ones two
twos two threes two fours one five two
sixes and so on and you can go through
and actually look at that if you want to
count them but a quick way to find out
your distribution of different values so
you might want to know how often the
word the is used versus the word and if
each word is represented as a unique
number
and along the set variables we might
want to know let me just put a note up
here
we're going to start looking at
intersection
and we might want to also know
differentiation
and neither
so when we're whoops neighbor
neither so when we're looking at now is
we want to know hey where do these two
arrays intersect and we have one two
three four five three four five six
seven we might want to know what is
common between the two arrays
um and so when we do that we have NP
intersect
and it's a 1D array one dimensional
array
and then we need to go ahead and put
array 1 array two
and if we run this
we can see they intersect at three four
five that's what they have common
and because we're going to go ahead and
go through these and look at a couple
different options let's change this from
intersect 1D
and we'll do the same thing we'll go
ahead and print this
so we might want to know the
intersection where they have
commonalities
another
unique word is Union of 1D so instead of
intersect
we want to know all the values that are
in both of them so here's our Union of
1D when we run that you can see we have
one two three four five six seven so
it's all the different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go is we want to know
what the set difference is
uh and so that's where the you'll see
that if you remember set we talked about
that being the what they call these
things
um so the set difference
of a 1D array when we run that you can
see that one is only in one array and
two was only in one array
and if we want to know uh what's in
Array one but not in Array two we might
want to know what is in Array one but
not two and what's in two but not one
and this would be the set X or 1D on
here so we have the four different
options here where we can do an
intersection what do they both have in
common we can do a union what are all
the unique values in both arrays
we can see the difference what's in
Array one but not array two so set diff
1D and then set X or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we're
talking there's a lot of different
little mathematical things going on in
numpy a lot of this can also be done in
pandas although usually the heavy
lifting is left for numpy because that's
what it's designed for let's go ahead
and open up another python 3.
setup in here
and so we want to explore what happens
when you want to display this this is
where it starts getting in my opinion a
little fun because you're actually
playing with it and you have something
to show people and we'll go ahead and
rename this we're going to call this uh
pandas and Pi plot
so pandas pipelot just so we can
remember for next time and we want to go
ahead and import the necessary libraries
we're going to import pandas as PD now
remember this is a data frame so we're
talking rows and columns and you'll see
how pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people and then
we're going to have numpy in the
background numpy works with pandas so a
lot of times you just import them by
default
Seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library so sometimes we use the Seaborn
because it kind of extends it's one of
the 100 packages that extends the
matplot library probably the most common
used because it has a lot of built-in
functionality almost by default I
usually just put Seaborn in there in
case I need it and of course we have
matplot Library as pipelot as PLT and
note we have as PD as NP as SNS as PLT
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your Imports I would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
uh it says Amber sign matplot Library
inline
that is for Jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this in a different
package you'll have a pop-up when it
goes to display the matplot library you
can with the most current version of
Jupiter usually leave that out and it
will still display it right on the page
as we go and we'll see what that looks
like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the Seaborn the sns.set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them just keep the
default one so we don't have to think
about it too much
and we of course have to run this the
reason we run this is because these
values are all set if we don't run this
and I access one of these afterward
it'll it'll crash
the cool thing about Jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it because you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to Anaconda and run your
install for these and then just come
back and run it you don't have to close
anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick where we have car equals
PD dot read underscore CSV and then we
have the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you are working with uh so it's
wherever you saved the file at and you
can see here I have um like my OneDrive
documents simply Learn Python data
analytics using python slash car CSV
it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get a CSV file and we have the make the
model the year the engine fuel type
engine horsepower cylinders and so on
um and this is just a comma separated
file so each row is like a row of data
think of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and as you can see right here it
has the make model so it has columns for
a header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of automatically pulling a lot of
this in so when you start seeing the
pandas on here you realize that you are
already like halfway done with getting
your data in I just love pandas for that
reason numpy also has it you can load a
CSV directly into numpy but we're
working with pandas and this is where it
really gets cool is I can come down here
and I can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out the
head is going to print the top values of
that data file we just ran in
and so you can see right here it does a
nice printout it's all nice and in line
because we're in jupyter Notebook I can
scroll back and forth and look at the
different data and just like we expected
we have our column it brought the header
right in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on and we're just looking at the
head so we got 0 1 2 3 4.
um you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two BMWs
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that data file and you can see
right here it numbered them all the way
up to
11913. oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file I didn't even look to
see how big the file was so you can
really easily get through and view the
different data in here when you're
talking about Big Data
you almost never just print out car in
fact let's see what happens when we do
if we run this and we just run the car
it's huge in fact it's so big that the
pandas automatically truncates it and
just does head plus tail so you can see
the two
um so we really don't want to look at
the whole thing I'm going to go back to
let's stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data it gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there I can zoom out if you want so you
can actually get a better View
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code I'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we of
course want to look at um
data types what's going on with our data
what does it look like now this you know
you show your when you're talking to
your shareholders they like to see these
nice easy to read charts they look like
a spreadsheet so it's a nice way of
displaying pieces of the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into the data science side of it
what are we working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year engine fuel type is an object if we
go up here you can see that there most
of them are
like you know it's a set manual rear
wheel drive so they might be very
limited number of types in there
uh and so forth and it's either going to
be a float64 an integer or an object is
the way it's going to read it on here
and the next thing you're going to know
is like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically we have here the make the
model the year the engine the size all
the way up to the MSRP
and um just out of something you'll see
come up a lot is whenever you're in
pandas and you type in dot values it
converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these so then
you end up in a numpy array so you'll
see a little switch in there in the way
that the data is actually stored and
that's true of any of these in this case
we want car dot columns
you have a total list of your car
columns
and like any good data um scientist we
want to start looking at analytical
summary of the data set what's going on
with our data so we can start trying to
piecemeal it together so we can do car
describe
and then we'll do is we'll do include
equals
all
so a nice Panda command is to describe
your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a make the model of the
year how many of each one how many
unique values of each one the top value
of each one what's most common the
frequency the mean clearly on some of
these it's an object so really can't
tell you what the average is it'd just
be the top ones the average I guess
the year what's the average year on
there all this stuff comes down here
your standard deviation your minimum
value your maximum value what's in the
lower quarter fifty percent Mark where's
that line at and what's in the upper 75
percent the top 25 percent going into
the max
now this next part is just cool this is
what we always wanted computers be back
like in the 90s instead of 5 000 lines
of code to do this maybe not five
thousand all right I built my own plot
Library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot was um
I don't know probably about 100 lines of
code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas we
generated that it's our data frame and
we have dot hist for histogram that is
the power of Seaborn now it's still
going to generate a numpy graph but
Seaborn sits on top and then we can do
the figure size this is just um so it
fits nicely on the paper on here and we
do something simple like this and you
can see here where it comes up and it
does say matplot library and does
subplots and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different pieces in our database and
we have our engine cylinders that's
always a good one because you can see
like they have some that are they had a
null on there so they came out as zero
um maybe a couple maybe one of them had
a two cylinder engine away back when
four is a common uh six a little less
common and then you see the eight
cylinder 12 cylinder engines but it's
got to be a Speedster or something
uh but you can see right here just
breaks it down so now you have how many
cars with how many whatever it is
cylinders horsepower and so on and it
does a nice job displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh um you're going into your demo it's
really nice just to be able to type that
in and boom there it is it can see it
all the way across
and we might want to zero in and use
like a box plot and this time we'll go
ahead and call the um Seaborn SNS box
plot and we're going to go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus engine horsepower
XY plot and the data comes from the car
so if we run this we end up with a nice
box plot
you see our mid-size Compact and large
you can see the variation there's our
outlier showing up there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car a
large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece of data and display
it for people who need to have it
reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
Seabourn box plot or sns.box plot
and then if we're going to back out and
we want a quick look at what they call
pair plotting we can run that and you
can see with the Seaborn it just does
all the work for you
it takes just a moment for to pull the
data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
and this grid if you look at this one
space here which is you might not be
able to see the small number it says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower to the year was built and
it's just flipped so everything to the
right of the middle diagonal is just the
rotation of what's on the left and as
you expect the engine horsepower gets
bigger and bigger and bigger as time
goes on so the the year was built the
further up in the year the more likely
you are to have a heavy horsepower
engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
couple a moment to process but right
away I get a nice view of all these
different information which I can look
at visually in and kind of see how
things group and look
now if I was doing a meeting I probably
wouldn't show all the data
one of the things I've learned over the
years is people myself included love to
show all our work you know we were
taught in school show all your work
prove what you know the CEO doesn't want
to see a huge grid of graphs I guarantee
it so we want to do is we want to go
ahead and drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're gonna I'm not really a car
person a guy in the back is obviously so
you have your engine fuel type we're
going to drop that we're going to drop
Market category vehicle style popularity
number of doors vehicle size and we have
the axes in here if you remember from
numpy we have to include that axis to
make it clear what we're working on
that's also true with pandas
and then we'll look at just that what it
looks like um from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year and so forth and we took
out the engine fuel type Market category
Etc
and this would look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas I
just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice spreadsheet for you you can just
look at it and view it very easily it's
also the same kind of view you're going
to get if you're working in spark or Pi
spark which is python for spark across
Big Data this is the kind of thing that
they they come up with this is why
pandas is so powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns and so you can
go in here and we can actually rename
the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals engine horsepower equals
horsepower this is just your standard
python dictionary
so it just Maps them out and you know
instead of having like a lengthy here we
had engine horsepower we just want
horsepower we don't need to know it's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed we have model year
and horsepower versus model year engine
horsepower engine cylinders and just
cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more and more readable the more
readable you get it the better and of
course we can also adjust the size a
little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also that's
just your control Mouse app or plus sign
you use in Chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way we
can look at the shape of the data so we
now have
um
11914 rows and 10 columns so you see
some similarities because pandas is
built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows and so we can do car and
look at this switch here we're doing a
selection this is a panda selection with
the brackets
but we want to select it based on
car.duplicated so how many duplicates on
there
so it's starting to look a little bit
different as far as how we access some
of the data in here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing a lot more
than we really feel like we should we
might go ahead and do like a car count
just to see how many rows we're dealing
with and then right after that we might
want to go ahead and say hey let's drop
duplicates so remember we did all the
duplicates on there so car equals car
dot drop duplicates and then we can
print the head again we'll just do car
head here and you can see the data on
there looks the same as before
uh and just note that we did car equals
car draw duplicates there are commands
in here where you can do where it
changes the actual value and it works on
some of them and not on others depending
on what you're doing but by default it
always returns a copy so when we do this
we're reassigning it to car
and you can see it's the same header but
we want to go ahead and do count and see
how the count changes let's go ahead and
run this and you can see here instead of
11 914 we have 10 925. so we've removed
about a hundred cars and we're
duplicated just slightly under 100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know
car is null so it's going to count the
values of null and then we want to sum
that up and when we do that we do the
car is null function.sum we end up with
HP the horsepower at 69 have null values
and 30 have cylinders have no values now
if you don't put the sum at the end it's
just going to return a mask with the
true false of is it null or is it not by
zero and one so you're summing up the
ones underneath each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value there's a lot of different ways to
fill it usually when you first start out
with the data a lot of them you just
drop your null values and you can see
here car dot drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped almost
another 100 values so from 10 1925 to 10
8 27. yeah maybe 75 or so values
so we've cleaned that this is really a
big part of cleaning data you need to
know how to get rid of your null values
or at least count them and what to do
with them
and of course if we go back to um
counting our null values we should now
have
null null values there we go and you'll
see there's zero null values
I don't know how many times I've been
running a model that doesn't take null
values and it crashes and I just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked
it's because I forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to uh finding outliers
and let's go ahead and bring that back
into our Seabourn and if you remember we
did a box plot earlier uh this time
we're going to do a box plot just on the
price and you can see here our price
value
and we have the deviation with the two
thinner bars on each side of the main
value and then as we get up here we have
all these outliers in fact we have one
way out here that's um probably a really
expensive high-end car is what we're
looking at
if you were doing fraud analysis you
would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like I said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at and we can
also look at the box plot for the
horsepower
and we'll put that in down here
and run that
and you can see again here's our
horsepower and it just jumps and there's
these really odd huge muscle cars out
here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more um as you start
displaying your data or your information
to your shareholders we're going to look
at plotting a histogram for the number
of cars per brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is we have with our car go back
over here here we go we have our make
value counts largest plot and we want to
do a kind equals bar
fig size 10.5
and right off the bat we jump up here
and we see Chevrolet it's going against
what was it it's um figure race Edition
the value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts and
compared to what the different cars are
Chevrolet puts out a lot of different
kinds of cars I didn't realize that they
made that many cars or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you looked at
this the first time you would have been
like well what the heck am I looking at
well we're looking at the number of cars
by make and then you can see here now
we're talking about the type of cars and
the different ones are put out Lotus I
guess only had a few different kinds of
cars over there very high-end cars
and then as uh doing data analytics and
as a data scientist one of the things I
am most interested in is the
relationship between the variables
so this is always a place to start we
want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure it
fits our graph we'll just go ahead and
set this one plot Figure Set to figure
size 2010. if you never use the matplot
library which is sitting behind Seaborn
whatever is in the PLT this is what's
loaded it's like a canvas you're
painting on so the second you load that
Pi plot as PLT anything you do to that
is affecting everything on it
uh and then we want to go ahead since
we're using Seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable C
for
relationships or correspondence
and car dot c-o-r-r that's a correlation
in Seabourn on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with Seabourn
let's put it into a nice heat map if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
means we're just using color as part of
our
setup so we have a nice visual
and we can see here that the Seaborn
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart we'll talk a little bit about
the color here in a second it prints out
a nice chart this is a chart I look at
as a data scientist these are the
numbers I want to look at and we'll just
highlight one of them here's cylinders
versus horsepower the closer to one the
higher the correlation so 0.788 pretty
high correlation between the number of
cylinders and how heavy the horsepower
is
I'm betting if you looked at the year
versus uh horsepower we just look at
that one here's year and horsepower
0.314 not as so much but if you combine
them uh you don't actually add them but
if you combine them you'll start to see
an increase in Horsepower per year and
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 0.78 is
a positive correlation you might notice
if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage so if we go here to horsepower
to mileage you get a nice negative we'll
do cylinders that's a bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus 0.6 so it's a negative
correlation the closer to -1 the more
the negative correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle
obviously the year correlates strictly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction pandas
goes Way Beyond this most the
functionality and numpy since pandas
sits on it is also in pandas and then it
even has additional features in it and
we use Seaborn pretty extensively
sitting on top over our pie plot so keep
in mind that our PI plot has a ton of
other features in it that we didn't even
touch on in here we couldn't even if you
had a soul course in it there's just so
many things hidden in there depending on
what your domain you're working on but
you can see here here's our Seaborn and
here's our matplot library that's all
our Graphics that we did and then the
Seaborn works really nicely with the
pandas we really like that
so that wraps up our demo part for today
let's learn about data manipulation in R
and here we will learn about deep layer
package and when we talk about this
d-plier package it is much faster and
much easier to read than base R so D
player package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt or data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package deployer by just
calling in library function and this can
be used for grouping by data summarizing
the data adding new variables selecting
different set of columns filtering our
data sets sorting it selecting it
arranging it or even mutating that is
basically creating new columns using
functions on exit existing variables so
let's see how we work with d player now
here I can basically get the package
here so I can just say install dot
packagesdp player now we already see the
the package here which is showing up so
I will just select this one I can do a
control enter and that will basically
set up the package package deployer
successfully unpacked so that is done
now you can start using this package by
just doing a library D player and this
was built it shows me my version of R so
let's also use a inbuilt data set that
is New York flights 13 so we can do
install.packages and that will search
and get that relevant data set
I can again Call It by using Library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a tabular format
which shows me year month day departure
time schedule departure time and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data which can help us in
understanding the data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here it shows me how
many variables we have so this is fine
now we can start using deployer and in
that we can use say filter function if
we would want to look in for specific
value now here we have the column as
month so I will do a filter now I'm
creating a variable F1 I'm using the
filter function on flights which we
already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically look at the month where the
month value is 0 7 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on F1
which shows me the data wherein you have
filtered out all the data based on month
being seven
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say F2 filter flights and here we will
say month is equal to 7 day is 3 and
then look at the value of F2 if you are
interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month 7 and days
three you could also look into a more
readable format by using view on F2 and
that gives me my selected result so we
are just extracting in some specific
value we can keep extending this so here
we can say flights is what we would want
to work on I'm using the filter function
so I can straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view I can also do a view in
this way I can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this I am
saying filter I would want to look at
the flights month being 0 9 day being 2
and origin being LGA and then that shows
me the value here and obviously you can
scroll and look at all the columns and
if you see the origin column it shows
the selected value so now we have
filtered out our data based on values in
three different columns now what we can
also do is we can use and or we can use
or operators so I could have done this
in a a little different way so I could
have said head which shows me initial
result I will do a flight So within my
head function I am passing in this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flight's data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we're given a value and I'll
say and and I'll again say flights
wherein I will select the day being two
and and remember when you talk about and
it is going to check if all the values
are met true so then you say flights
origin LGA and you look at the value so
in this way I can filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific in specifying all the columns
it makes the code more readable so let's
look at the values and here you are
looking at head which shows me based on
month day and then you can look for
further columns for other variables that
is origin being LGE now what we can also
do is we can do some slicing here to
select rows by particular position so I
can say slice and I would want to look
at rows one two five and I can do this
so you can always assign or look at the
view of this I can just do here so when
I did a slide one is to 5 it shows me my
entries for one to five now similarly we
can do is slice 5 to 10 and now you are
looking at 5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set and then you would
want to add it to your existing data
frame or you would want to add a new
column so this is where you use mutate
which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate so it's pretty simple so you
create a variable over delay now I would
want to do a mutate so that it adds a
new column so I am selecting my data
which is flights I will call the new
column as overall delay and then
basically
I can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure DeLay So let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view and you could have just look at
flights if you would want to compare so
you can look at the flights and this one
would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here and if you
do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 columns so we know
that the new column has been added
to
this overall DeLay So if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do an overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay the
computation remains same but at this
time if I look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure now you can
also use summarize and summarize
basically helps us in getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a summarize
and what we can do is we can look at our
data and we can say on what basis we
would want to summarize this particular
data so we can do a summarize function
now summarize on flights I will say
average airtime and I would want to
calculate an average so for that I'm
using inbuilt function called mean I
will do that on airtime column
so
let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what I'll do
is I will use the summarize function I
will say average air time and this one I
will look at mean of a time so let's see
if there is a a Time column I might be
let's look at this one and I will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at summarizing based on
airtime not the arrival time so air time
is how much time it takes in air for
this particular flight and we will want
to use the trans summarize function not
the transmute so summarize flights
average airtime and this one we will
calculate the mean of average airtime
and I will also do a n a removal which
is I am saying true so let's do this and
that basically shows me the average
airtime is 151
I can also do a total a time where I am
doing a summation of values or I can get
the standard deviation or I can
basically get multiple values such as
mean
I can say total air time where I am
doing a summation and then I can look at
other values which is if you would want
to put in standard deviation here you
could do that so let's look at the
result of this summarize and this
basically allows me to get some useful
information which is summarized based on
a particular function such as mean sum
standard deviation or
all three of them now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function so we can always
use the group by Clause now here we are
taking a different data set so we will
say for example let's look at head of Mt
cars and that is basically my data set
on empty cars now that shows me the
model of the car it shows me mileage
cylinder power this and your horsepower
and various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set so
here we can say let's do a grouping by
gear so there is a column called gear so
I will call it by gear I will look at my
data set and then what I'm using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol is called
piping so that basically feeds your
previous data frame into next one so
this is sometimes useful and you can get
this by just saying Ctrl shift and M and
you can then use this so we are going to
have piping so I am saying empty cars
now this is my original data set where I
did a head or I could have done a view
on this one if you would want to see it
in a more readable format and that
basically shows me the data so we are
using a different data set so I want to
group it by the gear column so I'm going
to call it by gear and this one takes my
data that is empty cars I'm using the
piping and then I am saying group the
data based on gear column that's done
now let's look at the value of by gear
or you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a internal object where your
data is grouped based on a particular
column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you your data
grouped based on a particular column now
I can again use the summarize function
where I would want to Now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so I am doing a summarize and here
I am going to say Gear 1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column and then I'm saying Gear 2
which is mean well you could give some
meaningful names to this and let's look
at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is sum and mean values
based on the gear
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear and I'm
again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear we had
grouped the data and we called it by
gear so we took our original data set Mt
cars but now within this particular data
which was grouped by gear I will take
this data set I will use the piping and
I will summarize it where I am saying
within this particular data set I would
want to get the sum or I would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values so what you are doing is you
are either looking at your original data
set or you are looking at the data which
was already grouped and then you can
look at the values now here what we can
do is we can Group by cylinder say might
be you are interested in looking at data
which is summarized based on the
cylinder column you can do that and then
for this buy cylinder I am doing a
piping where I am using the summarize
function and summarizing will then be
done based on the mean values of the
gear column or the horsepower so let's
do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample underscore n
function and Sample underscore
fraction for creating samples so for
this let's take the flights data set
again and we would want to get 15 random
values now that is done and it shows me
15 rows with some random values from the
data what you can also do is you can do
a portion of data by using sample
underscore fraction and here I'll say
flights I'll say 0.4 which will return
40 percent of the total data so this can
be useful when you are building your
machine learning where you would want to
split your data into training and test
might be you are interested in some
portion of the data so you can do this
which is very useful function and then
you can look at the value of that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use a range which is a
convenient way of sorting then your base
are sorting so for range function
let's do a view based on a range so we
will work on the flights data set which
we have and here what we would want to
do is we would want to arrange the
flight status set which is based on year
and departure time and we are doing a
view out of it so that basically gives
me the data which is arranged based on
your ear and departure time now I can do
a head to give me some highlighting of
that data now the piping operator what
we are using
can be used in these ways also so here I
will say DF I will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
DF which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are creating a variable called result
here now that has the arrange function
so what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so I would want to sort
the data but what data would I sort so I
will use sample n which will give me
some portion of the data or some sample
data now what is that sample data so
here we are using nesting that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here now this filter will work on
DF
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20 I will
say size is 5 and I would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so I'm using the Des on this
particular mileage column by default it
is always ascending so let's get the
result out of this which will basically
show me the mileage details in a
descending order so this is my data
frame and now we can look at the result
what we have created
so just do a view or do a head and look
at the view so here you see mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have not
only used an inbuilt function we have
not only arranged the data that is we
have sorted the data but we have sorted
the data based on a descending order on
a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20 and we
have also said we just need five random
samples now let's look at some other
examples so you can always do a multi
assignment so I can say filter
wherein I'm going to use DF which was
assigned Mt cars I am going to say
mileage should be greater than 20 then I
say B which is going to get a sample out
of a and I just want five random values
so let's look at that so we have B which
is
going to get a
set of five values from a now I will
create a result variable which will
arrange B which is sample data in a
descending order now let's look at the
result of this and that basically shows
me what we were seeing earlier so you
can do a multi assignment where you can
create a variable get a sample out of it
and then basically whatever is that
result you can assort that in a
descending or by default ascending order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator so piping so here I will say
result I am passing in my DF that's the
data set I'm using piping and which
basically tells what you need to do on
this particular data set so I'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then I'm going to push
that or forward it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this this is one
more way of doing it and then basically
you can look at the result so these are
some simple examples where you can use
your D plier with multiple assignments
or using your nesting to filter out the
data you can also do a a range which is
to sort the data you can get some random
samples out of it you can summarize the
data you can also summarize the data
based on one or two or multiple columns
and you can use some inbuilt functions
to summarize the data based on some
functions which are applied on the
variables or on the columns
you can transmute it where you would be
interested in only looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or to filter out the
data so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example DF where I have my data
let's look at this one and if I just do
a DF at this point it shows me my data
set and if you would be interested only
in particular column then your D player
also allows you to either we can do a
filter or we can simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
our data so for example I'll say DF
underscore I'm interested in mileage I'm
interested in Horsepower might be I'm
interested in your cylinders in this and
for this one what I can do is when I
would want to do a select I can
basically say
selected DF let's call it some name I
can say control shift M which is for
piping and then basically what you can
do is you can do a select and you can
choose your columns so I was interested
in mileage I was interested in
horsepower
I was interested in cylinder and here
what I'm doing is I'm using a select
where I can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and I'm sorry here we will have to give
it TF this is where you are passing in
your data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a DF or head on DF
underscore mileage horsepower cylinder
and look at the selected result so you
can be looking at selective columns I
could have done this filter but filter
will always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than four or something else but
when you do a select you are selecting
specific columns so view always gives
you all the columns head gives you
highlight but then select can be useful
when we are interested in looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use the player for manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tider and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation done
using your tider package let's learn
about that IDR package which makes it
easy to tidy your data and this
basically helps you creating a more
cleaner data so which is easy to
visualize and model now this comes with
the mainly four functions so you have
gather which makes your data wide or it
makes wide data longer so that is
basically used to stack up multiple
columns you have spread function which
makes long data wider that is stacking
the data together or stack if you would
want to unstack the data to data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes and then your spread can
spread the data across multiple columns
you have separate which is function with
splits single column into multiple
columns and to complement that you have
one more function which is unite and
that combines multiple columns into
single columns so these are four main
functions which are used in your tider
package so let's look how we work with
this so let me bring up my R Studio here
now for this first is let me just clean
up my screen here doing a control l so I
will install the package it is already
installed but we can just do a control
enter and then
I can say do you want to restart R prior
to reinstall Store install I'll say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package did tidyr the rest
idrs has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package with using our
library function
and that was built under R version 3.6
now I can basically start using these
functions so for example here we are
creating a data frame so let's say n is
and then we basically would say we will
call it white now that's the variable
name I'm using the data dot frame
function I am saying ID which will be 1
to n so that will take the values from 1
to 10 and then these are the values
which have
10 entries so this is a vector Phase 1
phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it now that's done we
can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the ID column and it has phase dot 1
phase.2 and phase.3 now we can use our
function so for example use so we are
using wide as a data frame
then I'm saying response time so that
will be basically one more column and
then you have your columns which you
would want to
basically stack so I'm saying from phase
one to phase three so let's do this and
once this is done let's have a look at
our variable long so this one shows me
that I have an ID column
I have the response time column and I
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have phase dot 1 phase
dot two and phase dot three so I have
all the columns are being stacked here
so all my data so now I have totally 30
entries in this one so this is basically
using your gather function now sometimes
we may want to use a separate function
now separate function is basically
splitting a single column into multiple
columns so which we would want to use
when multiple variables are captured in
a single variable column okay so let's
look at an example of this one so let's
say long separate that's what we will
call we will work on this long which has
all the data stacked in as the columns
we selected then I am saying separate I
want the face column and then I would
say when I separate the columns what are
my column names now I could all also
give a separator by giving a comma and
then mentioning the separator if that is
required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the column which we used so we were
doing a face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
Target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
Target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use a
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here we will call
it long Unite
and we will take long separate which was
separating the data we want to unite so
we will take phase Target number and we
want to have a separator between them so
let's basically do this and now let's
look at the result of this unite so you
see you have the face and Target merge
together so you have phase dot one the
separator is dot as we have mentioned
and we have United multiple columns so
this is one more function of your tider
which helps you basically tidy up your
data or put it in a particular way now
then you have your spread function and
this is basically for unstacking so that
is if you have if you would want to
convert a stack to data or if you would
want to unstack the data which is of
same attributes spread can be used so
that you can spread the data across
multiple columns so it will take two
columns say key in value and spread it
into multiple columns so it makes long
data wider so we can look at this one we
will say long unite I'm using the piping
I will use the spread function I'll work
on the face column and response time and
let's do this and then let's do a view
on this so it tells me our data is back
in the shape as it was in the beginning
so these are four functions which are
very helpful when we work with tider
package
so let's learn about visualization
and here we will learn about R which can
be used for your visualization now one
thing which we need to understand is
because of our ability to see patterns
which is highly developed we can
understand the data better if we can
visualize it so the efficient way or
effective way to understand what is in
our data or what we have understood in
our data we should or we can use
graphical displays that is your data
visualization so there are actually two
types of data visualizations so you have
exploratory data visualization which
helps us to understand the data and then
you have explanatory visualization which
helps us to share our understanding with
others so when you talk about r r
provides various tools and packages to
create data visualizations
and which can be used for both kind of
data analysis or both kind of
visualizations so when you talk about
exploratory data and visualization the
key is to keep all the potentially
relevant details together now the
objective when we talk about exploratory
data analysis is to help you see what is
in your data
and the main question is how much
details can we interpret
now when you talk about different
functions which we see here such as plot
which is more for a generic uh plotting
you have bar plot which is used to plot
data using rectangular bar so you can
say creating bar charts you have
histogram or hist function to create
histograms where you look at the
frequency
of the data or basically used to look at
the central tendency of the data you
have box plot which is used to represent
data in the form of quartiles you have
GG plot which is a package which enables
a user to create sophisticated
visualizations with the little code
using the grammar of graphics and then
you have plotly or plot l y it creates
interactive web-based graphs via the
open source JavaScript graphing library
now before we see some examples here
let's also talk about when you talk
about plotting let's also try to
understand what kind of plots you can
have and what kind of techniques you
have so let me open up my R Studio here
now for example I can pull out a
particular data set and let's look at
this one so here I can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information now what I can do is I can
install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then I
can simply do a plot wherein I am doing
a plot on chickway data set so let's see
what does that show it summarizes the
relationship between four variables in
chickweight data frame which is in our
built-in data set package now from these
plots we can see for example weight
varies systematically over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets now
when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some editorial decisions what
features we would want to highlight for
emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated right so there are different
ways of doing it now when you talk about
your graphics or visualizations you have
I would say three different types or you
can say four so you have the base
Graphics which is easiest to learn now
here we are having an example of Base
Graphics where I can use the base
Graphics I can get a
data set using Library
then I can simply create using plot
function to generate a simple scatter
plot of calories with sugar from us
serial data frame in the mass package
and then I can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of Base
Graphics now you also have what we call
as grid Graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools
now you also have latest Graphics which
is general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your GG plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid Graphics so you
have different ways now here since I
already have used library and I have the
data set I can just do a x so I can
assign the sugar related values to X and
calories related value to Y then I can
use one more which is Library function
and calling in Grid now I can basically
use functions such as push viewport if I
would want to create a plot using your
grid Graphics to create the similar kind
of plot which we created using base
Graphics but this will give you much
more power than base Graphics it will
have a steep learning curve but it is
usually useful so I can do this where
I'm saying push view port then I can
basically say I would want to have a
data viewport I would say different
functions of your grid package so I'm
saying rectangle you have x axis y-axis
given some points here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can basically create a
simple grid Graphics based plot here now
there are different other options which
we can use to create plots now before we
go into understanding how you create
plots let me just give you a brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used so here we will
look at these different plots now for
example we have a bar chart which is a
graph which shows comparisons across
discrete categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared and y-axis
which represents a measured value and
height of the bars are proportional to
measured values Now to create different
kind of charts you can use ggplot which
is a package for creating graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits and that is a part
of Tidy words ecosystem so it takes each
component of graph accesses you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects and you can build graphs on
particular data you can modify each of
those components in a way that's more
flexible and user friendly you can if
you are not providing details for the
components then ggplot will use sensible
defaults and this basically makes it a
powerful and flexible tool now here
are different options when you use your
GG plot such as you can use geom or what
we call as geometric objects to form the
basis of different type of graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have Scatter Plots that is underscore
point you have underscore box plot for
box plots you have quartile for
continuous X violin for richer display
of distribution and Jitter for small
data so here is some simple example
where I would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one where we are using
Library function to get the ggplot2
package then basically we would want to
look into the mileage data we would want
to look at the structure of it and then
we can basically get the Tidy verse
package finally we can create a bar
chart using jio underscore bar
and we can basically also mention what
would be in x axis now you can also give
different colors to basically add more
meaning to your data you could also go
for stacked bar charts so here we are
actually telling ggplot to map the data
in the drive column to fill the
aesthetic so here I am giving
aesthetic access class and I'm saying
what is the data we need to have and
then we are using geom underscore bar so
you can also have dodged bar
in your GG plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using your
position as position underscore Dodge
okay now you can obviously use your
different packages which are inbuilt and
you can create your bar charts and you
have other kind of graphs such as line
graph which is basically a type of graph
that displays information as a series of
data points connected by straight line
segments such as this one and for this
one we are using if you see jio
underscore line now you can also create
a scatter plot which is a two
dimensional data visualization that uses
points to graph the values of two
different variables one in an x-axis one
on y-axis like what we saw in base
Graphics example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship or lack
of relationship between two variables
and you also have histogram which I
mentioned is mainly to look at the
distribution of a data to look at the
central tendency of the data basically
looking at your large amount of data or
for a single variable you would be
interested in saying where is more data
found in terms of frequency whereas
lesser data found in the graph how close
the data is towards its mid point or
what we call as mean median mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins so these are some Basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of Base Graphics or grid
Graphics now here let's do an example of
pie chart for different products and
units sold so you want to create a graph
for this first let's create a vector and
pass in the value here now I can also
create labels which I would want to
assign to these values and then
basically I can plot the chart by saying
Pi so that's the kind of chart which I
would want to create and I would say the
data would be X and labels so let's do
this and that shows me a simple pie
chart now I can also give main details
here so instead of just doing a pi x
comma labels I can say what is the main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a simple
plot now I can also find out what is the
percentage and then basically I would be
interested in plotting the pie chart
which takes X which takes the labels
which will be the percentage which we
are calculating here by doing a round
function and then you can basically give
details to your graph you can say what
color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be in your chart
what are the values and then basically
fill up the colors so let's run this one
and that shows me the percentage which
was calculated and it gives me the
details and we can always have a look at
our plot now if you would want to go for
a 3D pie chart then you can get the
package which is plotrix let's use that
by calling in the library function let's
pass in some data to X and let's give
some values or labels which will make
more meaning to the data and then let's
plot the 3D graph so I'm saying Pi 3D
here where I'm using X and labels
then I'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like and basically give the
values so it also takes the title when
you say Main and by chart of countries
now let's create data for graph so again
we are having a variable here we are
created using the C function creating a
vector and then let's create a histogram
for this one
where I would say xlab what would be
your data around x axis what is the
color what is the border and here I am
creating a simple histogram
which as I discussed earlier will always
show your values on the x-axis and
y-axis is more of frequency and then you
can look at the set of values and what
is their frequency and we can basically
use this histogram for exploratory data
analysis look at the data try to
understand what is the central tendency
of your data values now we can also give
some limits by using the x-lim and Y Lim
and then I can also specify what is the
limit so we have given some values here
wherein we have said your X limit is 0
to 40 and Y limit is 0 to 5. now if you
compare this with the previous one which
we had created this one based on the
frequency had taken the limits but we
can assign limits explicitly by giving
this and then create a histogram which
makes more meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality let's view this to see what
does that data contain so you have ozone
solar wind temperature month and the day
so this is the kind of information we
have in the air quality now let's use
the plot function to draw a scatter plot
where as I mentioned you would be
interested in analyzing variables and
see what is the relationship between
them so to plot a graph between ozone
and wind values so we will say plot we
will say the data which is air quality
from that I would be interested in the
ozone column or ozone field and the wind
field I can create a plot based on this
now I can also be saying what should be
the color what is the type of the data
which you would want to create and you
can look at the info information so you
can create a histogram you can create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for tick weight where
we did a base Graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone and then
that's your ozone concentration you have
your ylab which is the number of
instances you have what is the title
ozone levels in New York City what is
the color so these are the details what
we have given with our plot function and
let's look at the data so it just tells
me that this is the ozone concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data now we
could also create a histogram by picking
up a particular column that is such as
solar from your air quality and that
basically shows me the frequency of
solar values and we can then try to find
out what is the made what is the mean
what is the standard deviation and so on
you can also look at your histogram and
try to understand if it is left skewed
and right skewed so we can do that now
here let's get the temperature out from
this particular data set let's create a
histogram on temperature and that
basically shows me the frequency of the
temperature values and what values have
the most frequency or most occurrence
now you can create a histogram with
labels
so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with non-uniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then
passing in your temperature you can say
what will be the main what is the title
what will be your X lab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color what is the Border
what are the breaks you would want to
have for your bars and you can simply
create a histogram using this so This
basically takes the breaks which we have
given such as 55 to 60 60 to 70 70 to 75
and so on so this is basically creating
a histogram with non-uniform width and
it purely depends on the kind of values
what you have now you can also create a
box plot which sometimes helps us in
understanding the the data quartiles
also understanding our outliers so you
can create multiple box plots based on
the data from air quality so we'll
select all the data and then we'll do
some slicing on the data so let's create
a box plot which tells me the values and
if you look at these points here like
single dots these are basically your
outliers we can learn about that more in
later sections so you can use your GG
plot to library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install.packages and get ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart R and
I can say yes so let it get the package
I think the package was already there
and now
let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that I have the
library function
and let's do a attach where I'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then I will create a variable P1 I
will use ggplot I will pass in my data
I'll give the Aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot to basically create a plot
which gives me the box plot for the
values here and this is based on the
cylinders which is there in your data so
we can always look at what does our data
contain and what kind of values or
features are available in the data now
let's create a box plot we will also use
the coordinate function and that
basically gives me based on the data so
I've changed the coordinates now if you
look at the previous one where we
created a plot we had mileage on the
y-axis and cylinders
on the x-axis now I did a coordinate
flip and that's like your transpose
function so you have created the box
plot but you have just flipped the
coordinates you can create a box plot
and then say fill which is the factor of
cylinder so that can be used to fill up
the values in your box plot now what we
can also do is we can create factors so
we have learned about factors earlier
which is usually used to work on
categorical variables so here let's
create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have am you
have cylinder and if you look at the
factors which we have created we have
passed our data what is the field or the
column we are interested in what is the
level of values there and what are the
labels for those values right so we have
learned about factors you can always
look into the previous section and learn
more about factors now let's create a
scatter plot by using the ggplot
function again we will use the data as
MD cars I will go for mapping option and
then I will give my Aesthetics that is
what would be x what would be your Y and
you also would want to use what kind of
function you are using so let's go for
geompon point and that basically helps
me in creating a scatter plot now you
can create a scatter plot by factors
so here we will say GG plot so notice in
all of these cases depending on the kind
of data you have depending on the kind
of plot you are interested in you will
use the GG plot and then basically a
function with that or the inbuilt
package so here I'm saying data is empty
cars I am going for mapping which
basically will take the values for your
X and Y what is the color and the
coloring will be done based on the
factor values now if you remember
factors will obviously have some levels
and those levels will basically help you
in differentiating between your
categorical variables so I'm saying as
dot Factor on cylinder and then I'm
using geompoint to basically create the
scatter plot so let's do this
and I can look at the values of this one
so it says must be there is an error
which says must at least one color from
the Hue palette so let's look at that
one so the error which we were facing
when we gave color as the factor values
was because when you look at these
factors which were created with some
labels if we look at the values of these
it tells me there are any values in that
particular column similarly your gear or
similarly you can completely look at the
complete data set it tells me cylinder
you have am you have care now these have
some we have created some labels but
these have any values so what we can do
is we can create a scatter plot as we
did earlier by giving the Aesthetics and
that's a simple scatter plot wherein I'm
also using geompoint so that I can have
these points by defaults or with
defaults you can also give a color
specific basically if you would want to
have different kind of data in the same
plot or I can create Scatter Plots by
different sizes by giving a size or I
can give a color and size and that's
again one way in which you can create
your Scatter Plots now let's also see
how you can visualize one more data set
which is MPG so I can also do it in this
way where I set GG plot 2 and then pass
in look at the data set what we have
here you can just do a view on this to
see what my data contains if the fields
have any any values if that's going to
affect your plotting so now what we can
do is we can create a bar plot or a bar
chart so I am saying GG plot the data
would be as we have given in previous
lines that is GG plot 2 MPG then I will
say what should be in my Aesthetics and
what kind of
chart are you going to create so I'm
saying geom underscore bar so that's my
bar chart and that has basically your
class and count now you can create a
stacked bar chart where your information
is stacked in the same bars and we are
still using the same data we are going
for Aesthetics which is class and then
when you say geome bar which creates
your stack bar we will use fill which is
Drive
and we can always go back and look at
our data for example you can always look
into this so you have the drive column
here and you are also working on this
complete data set so let's go ahead and
create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked here now you can do a Dodge by
giving the position as Dodge so we are
still going to go for a stack chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful you can use this by using
geompoint where you are mapping and you
are specifying what are your Aesthetics
so we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class and we have different
classes and based on that my points have
been colored now you can also use a plot
lyu or plotly Library so let's install
this one
I will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then I can access that package using
Library function and then create a
variable to which you are assigning your
plot underscore ly plot so data is empty
cars what will be your x-axis what will
be your y-axis and details on your
marker which we have given wherein I
will give a list which is size color
which is a combination and then you have
your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where I'm
going to use plot l y
and let's look at this plot
so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot l y and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data so this
is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or how you can have your
graphics or visualization used to
understand your data obviously there are
much more examples much more ways in
which you can pass into your plot
functions or your ggplot and the inbuilt
packages which are available in R for
your visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis or explanatory
data analysis so try these graphs and
see if you can change these options and
try or create new visualizations
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this session where we will
learn on time series analysis using our
programming language so this is
basically a mini project where we will
look at time series data and how we can
analyze it visualize it to basically
find some important information or
gather insights from the data now when
you talk about time series analysis time
series is basically any data set where
your values are measured at different
points in time so when you talk about
time series data data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example hourly weather measurements
you have daily counts of website visits
monthly sales total and so on so when
you talk about time series that can also
be irregularly spaced and sporadic for
example timestamp data in computer
systems event log or history of 911
emergency calls now when we work with
time series data for example here I am
taking a energy data set we can see how
techniques such as time based indexing
resampling rolling windows can help us
explore variations in electricity demand
and renewable energy Supply over time
now here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which I am considering so
there is this is open Power Systems data
set and here is the data set I have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption and then you
have data for wind and solar and wind
plus solar so in certain cases you have
only the date and the consumption but
then if we scroll down we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a Time series data set
which we would want to work on sometimes
you may also have the data collected
which just does not have the time but it
may also have time stamp that is it
would have say hour minutes and seconds
we can work on this time series data we
can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long term Trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how do wind and solar
power production compare with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find a lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically cold
or you have this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my GitHub
repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I have
given the documentation sample data set
and also your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your
rstudio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame
from this data set now here if you see I
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column I
am also giving row dot names and I'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as I showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
update consumption wind solar wind plus
solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just create this let's look at what does
this data frame contain and here if you
see it shows me some data which has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so I can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data I can also do a tail and look
at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind solar wind dot solar and
that basically has n a values so there
are missing values but let's look at the
tail and that tells me that there is
some data available for wind and solar
and wind solar now we can always look in
a tabular format using View
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see any values but if I
really scroll down
I can see some values which would be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so I can just use view now I can
look at the dimensions of this
particular object
and that tells me there are 400
4384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can be useful but I also look at my
other columns they are of the num types
so that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if I try to
do this this will show me that this is
null because date as a column does not
exist because we created it as an index
so if I look at row names
and then I search for my data show me
the index column or row dot names it
tells me these are the values that's the
date column which we are seeing here now
we can access a specific row by just
doing a my data and give the index value
or row name value so let's look at that
and that shows me based on this index
you are looking at the value you can
obviously search for a different date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector and you can give range of
values so that is 0 1 2006 to 4 of
January and we can look at this one so
it shows me
these are the values so here actually
I'm not giving a range but I'm just
selecting multiple values from row dot
names now we already know that in R you
have a summary function so you can
always do a summary and that gives you
for each column it gives you minimum
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values so we are
looking at consumption we are looking at
wind solar and wind dot solar now this
is good but then if I would want to
really visualize the data access the
data do some analysis then it would be
good to take all the columns and then we
can later decide to change the data type
of say date column if we want to use it
so earlier I was using date as row dot
names or the name of the rows or index
what you call in any other programming
language so here I will just use my data
set and I'll say header as true I'm
calling it my data 2. let's look at the
data and this one shows me
five columns wherein My First Column is
the date consumption wind solar and so
on now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type
so it tells me that if now I'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor with 4 384 levels and
these are the values so it is not in a
date time format it's a factor now what
we can do is we can convert this into a
date format how do we do that so let's
have a variable X and I'm going to use
as dot date function and I'm going to
pass in my date column so that's
assigned to X now let's look at the head
of X and it shows me the values we will
also see what kind of class it is and we
will look at the structure of X so class
already says it is date type and look at
the structure so it shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into X now how do I
basically extract values out of it or
make it a part of data frame so first I
will use so all once it has been
converted in date format I will go for
as dot numeric and here I will create a
variable called year and I will just do
a format on X which is basically of date
type and then I'm saying percentage y so
that will get me the ear component out
of this let's look at the values that
shows me year component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if I look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what I can do is I can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c byte that is
column bind and I will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me date so
that should be date format consumption
now this one might not be date format
but we'll see you have consumption wind
solar and we have extracted the year
month and day which can help us for
group by we can do some aggregations we
can do a plotting and we can do various
things by these additional columns now
let's look at first three rows here so
I'll say one is to 3 for my data 2 and
that shows me some data here you can
always do a head and look at the sample
of data so that basically shows me month
day your columns and then you have your
date now what we can do is we would want
to visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as I said if we want to visualize the
data say for example I want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here gigawatt
hours so if I would want to create this
visual to basically understand the
pattern of the data how do we do it so
we can you create a line plot of
full-time series of Germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is I can straight away
use the plot method I can then say what
would be in my x-axis what would be on
my y-axis what would be the type of
graph I would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so I am saying my data 2
I'm extracting the year column and here
I am taking the consumption so let's
create a plot and here if you see we are
looking at a plot we do see some tick
times and we see that the data has been
divided with every two years so from
2006 onwards to 2016 but then really
this data does not give me uh you know a
very useful way of looking at the rate
or understanding it might be what I can
do is I can use the same way but I can
give apart from x axis and y axis I can
say that limits that is X limit is 2006
to 2018 and Y limit is from 800 to 1700
so we can do this and let's look at this
again this is a plot but it really does
not help me in visualizing and
understanding the data so what are the
better options
I can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns so as of now we will
just keep it as it is par
MF row now if I would want to plot I can
straight away give the column name so I
am interested in getting the consumption
now I can just do a plot I'll say my
data 2 and I will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here
from our data so consumption was the
second column so I can just do a plot in
a straight away way without mentioning
your x-axis y-axis limits and so on and
if you look at this this one is giving
me a pattern now here I am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph and
we are looking at the data it does show
me some kind of pattern but might be we
can make it more meaningful so I can do
it this way where I say my data second
column let's give access as ER x axis
y-axis is consumption now that has
changed the x-axis and y-axis now I can
also give some more details I can say
type should be line I have the line
width I'm saying color is blue and let's
do this so this looks more meaningful
maybe shows a wavering pattern of
consumption over years I can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying X limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018. I can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so I can do a
plot I can choose column second X lab
which is x-axis y-axis type is line
width giving X limit y limit and then
I'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph and then basically you
are looking at the line graph now those
are the options which you can do either
you could be very specific or you could
just give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details now what we can
do is if we would want to look at this
data and understand it better rather
than just looking at a simple line I can
take the log values so here I am saying
log of my data to Second column so I'm
taking log values of consumption and I'm
taking the difference of logs so I can
say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it by some number so rest
Remains the Same I'm changing the color
and let's look at this plot and you see
this basically is giving me a better
pattern which makes meaning here we see
the log values so this is you are using
a simple plot function
in R you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so I'll
say no I will access this by using the
library ggplot 2.
and now I can use ggplot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data too that's the data frame I am
saying type as o and when I'm saying
line I am basically going to use x axis
which is here Y is consumption and let's
look at this plot so again we are back
to the one which we were doing earlier
really does not make any sense gives us
some data but then really does not give
me enough information I can
in my Aesthetics I can say x is here Ys
consumption I can do a grouping and then
I can give line and plot so again we
have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so I am just doing the
same thing here and I'm looking at line
type being test I'm using the GG plots
other methods such as geomline and
geompoint to give me more information
and if I look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but I would
still prefer the way we were doing with
plot
now we can change the color and
obviously add details to it so what we
see is when you use the plot method
which I did earlier it was choosing
pretty good tick locations that is every
two years and labels the years for the
x-axis which was helpful right but with
these data points which we were seeing
here
or say for example this one
or say this one
or say this one we are looking at some
data but then that really is quite
crowded and it is hard to read you can
look at the values but then it really
does not give you enough information so
we can go for plot method but then we
will see how we can consider different
data now if I would want to plot the
solar and wind time series so let's see
how do we do that
so wind column is what I'm interested in
so first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so I'm saying
minimum I'm saying let's put in here my
data to
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns we know
consumption is the second column when
does the third column and you have solar
as the fourth and this one is the fifth
so let's say let's find out the minimum
of each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column and here I'm also
saying remove the any values because we
do not want use so let's like look at
the minimum that shows me
5.7757 what is the maximum value it is
826 so that also helps me in giving a
limit if I want to plot wind on y-axis I
can give a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and win plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be held full
when you would want to plot multiple
graphs or give some limits so that's
fine now for multiple plots as I said
instead of having one plot let's plot
consumption and wind and solar and try
to see a pattern so I can say par
function and I will say three rows and
one column so now when I start plotting
you will see you will have multiple
plots in one single window so let's see
how we do it so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier and let's
look at the data so that gives me some
data you can always do a zoom and you
can look at the data you can basically
expand this graph or you can reduce this
graph to see what kind of pattern we
have in consumption similarly we can
basically choose date being x-axis my
consumption being y-axis right so this
is being more specific because here we
have a range but it really does not give
me enough information so I will
basically give x-axis y-axis I will give
the name that is daily totals and then I
will basically give consumption color
and Y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this and now
we can look at the data here so let's
see this data makes a little more
meaning because we are looking at the
dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me how the data pattern is
changing for consumption now this is for
consumption so what we can do is we can
also extract specific data so if you see
here I have done some testing where I am
saying okay I would want to get a date
specifically
I would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just change the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it it would be good if we can convert
a column into date time format and put
that in our data frame now let's look at
the plot 2 this is mainly for your
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so here I see it is solar
data and I can plot this one to see how
it looks like
and that tells me from 2006 onwards we
have some pattern I can be more specific
where I say I would be giving date and
then
the column for solar x axis Y axis what
is the type what is the Y limit and what
is the color it is always good to
specify your X and Y axis give a name
rather than let it automatically pick up
now this makes more meaning because it
shows me some dates similarly we can do
for wind so either you do it just by
giving the column
or you give your X and Y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot 3 this one we can choose
plot 2 we can choose plot one and we can
put all that data in one graph so that's
when you are putting in multi plots in
one particular graph you can always do a
zoom you can always look at the data
right and this is usually useful to look
at the pattern what kind of pattern we
see what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window and let's basically plot
time series in a single year so what we
have seen is that when you look at the
plot method it was quite crowded then we
looked at solar and wind and if you
compare that you will see your
consumption pattern your solar pattern
your wind pattern and basically we can
see from this particular data data some
kind of pattern so electricity
consumption is highest in the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in Winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year further into March at a particular
point of time and then it drops down so
electricity consumption is highest in
Winter and that might be due to
electrical Heating and increased
lighting usage and lowest in summer now
when you look at electricity consumption
appears to split into two clusters we
can always look at the consumption one
with oscillation centered roundly around
1400 gigawatts so you can always look at
1400 gigawatts and you see all the
values here which are in that particular
consumption another with fewer and more
scattered data points entries roughed
around 1150 so if you really expand this
you can see you will have lot of data
points at this point
now we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production that is
highest in summer when sunlight is most
abundant and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you're
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge you are you know knowledge of
business to understand how this goes if
you look at wind power production that's
again highest in Winters and drops down
in summer so due to stronger winds and
more frequent storms and lowest in
summer so there is some kind of
increasing Trend in wind power
production over years which we can see
here
over the years
and all the time series data what we are
looking at is referring or showing us
some kind of seasonality that is we are
looking at seasonality in which a
pattern is repeating again and again at
regular times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons for example
if you look at retail stale sales data
uh that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months
so seasonality when we say can occur on
other time scales so the plots what we
are seeing here they are fine but if you
look at those plots they might show some
kind of weekly seasonality also so in
your consumption corresponding to
weekdays and weekends so let's plot for
one single year now how do I do that so
first is I will look at my data too
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is Factor other columns which
are all numerics now like we did earlier
I'll repeat this step where I'm going to
convert the date column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what I want to do is I want to add
this
as to my data frame so I will create a
variable called mod data and this one
will have as data and I'm formatting the
value of x which is date time into month
day and year so let's do that and now
you look at the mod data which I created
like modified data so this is the format
I have it is in date type if you
carefully see here and then I can look
at the head of it so it saves me mod
data now we are what we did here is when
I said my data 3
so my data 3 we did a c bind and I did a
mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data
too so my new data frame is my data 3.
let's look at the structure of it and
you see there is this date column I can
delete it I can remove it I can let it
be right so that depends on our choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular year now how do you do that
so this is some wrangling so I will say
my data 4 let's call it my data 4 and I
will use subset function so subset will
work on my data 3 that's the data and
what I'll do is I will do a subset how
does how is the subset found so I'll say
take the mod data column the value
should be greater than or equal to 2017
and should be less than
2017 December 31st so I'm getting data
for one year and I'm storing it as my
data four
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data now let's do a plotting of this
where I will only create a plot for one
year so I'm saying my data 4 that's my
new
data what we got
so here I am going to take the first
column
which is mod data
I am going to take the third column
which is consumption so I'm looking at
the date format for one year consumption
values for it and then rest of the
things as we have done earlier let's
look at the plot and this makes more
meaning right so when you look at this
plot it tells me Jan to Jan it shows me
some kind of pattern where I have
divided the year into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so Jan and March and May and July
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where I've broken it down into
months so this is where you have taken
time series in a single year to
investigate further and this is what we
see right now we can clearly see there
are some weekly oscillations what one
more interesting feature is that at this
level of granularity that is when you're
looking at yearly data there is a
drastic decrease in electricity
consumption in early January and late
December during the holidays or probably
we can assume that this is holidays now
I can zoom in further and look at just
Jan and Feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data 3 I was doing a subset
and I was giving the date but this time
I will make it more narrower so I'll say
my data 4 I will say subset from my data
and I will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format I
will choose the starting date as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is Jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this now again as I said earlier
let's find out the minimum of this from
the First Column so that is basically
your mod data so let's look into this
one and that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the value so this one tells me
Jan 17 January 1 and maximum is
your
Feb 28th second month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I'm
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I am giving some naming
convention for sorry namings for your
x-axis y-axis
what is my consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see I'm using X limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and Y limit so let's look at this data
and if you look at this data it is
specifically for two months and again I
can look at the pattern here what I can
also do is I can add some grid here
so I can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now I can add
a line here using AB line and then I can
basically choose what lines I would want
to add horizontally so that basically
allows me to dissect the data and look
at data in a more meaningful way I can
also add vertical lines so vertical
lines is I'm saying sequence will be
minimum maximum and I'm saying an
interval of 7
so let's do this and this basically has
added some lines every week and you can
see at the end of week it is dropping
and then it is starting again it Peaks
somewhere in the mid of the week and
again it drops down so this is you're
looking at your consumption data right
now what we can also do is we can create
some box plots so when we looked at
zooming in data for Jan and Feb you can
add some data points like this so
consumption is highest on the weekdays
as I showed you here and lowest on the
weekends so this is what we are seeing
when we are breaking the data or zooming
it further for a couple of months so we
have vertical grid lines and we have
nicely formatted tick labels that is Jan
first Jan 15 Feb first and so on so we
can easily tell which days are weekdays
and weekends with use of these grid
lines and basically breaking it down so
there are many other ways to actually
visualize is your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use use
histograms and so on now moving further
we would want to explore the seasonality
right so when you further explore the
seasonality of our data we can use box
plots basically to group the data by
different time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so I can just do a simple box
plot and I can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
plot it is basically a visual display of
your Phi number summary that is you want
to look at your mean median you want to
look at your 25th percentile 50
percentile or 75th percentile so we can
use a quantile function use the
consumption column and then you
basically give a vector which shows you
Phi number summary so that's your
quantile and then let's do a box plot so
if you are looking at quantile it tells
me what is the minimum what is 25th
percentile 50 75th and 100 that's from
my consumption column so let's create a
box plot for consumption let's give it a
name as consumption let's give y-axis as
consumption and a limit for y-axis now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the year
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on year
so here I can give x axis y axis and I
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now I'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me 5 percentile or
sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot by just
giving consumption yearly grouped and
here I am giving the title as
consumption Y axis x axis and y limit
wherein I can also use less so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me the tick
points if you compare this one to the
previous graph so when I created this
previous graph I had to 2006 2008 and I
had from 600 to 1800 and if I go for the
next one I am basically seeing more
useful information now let's look at
monthly data so I would want to group it
based on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where I'm looking at
months
and I could select a particular year or
I can just do a grouping based on months
so I can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this now
let's create a box plot for consumption
which is monthly data and let's give it
a color let's look at the wind data
which is again grouped monthly and let's
look at the solar data which is grouped
monthly now if I zoom in it basically
gives me the seasonality of the data for
your wind for your consumption for your
solar so what we are doing is we are
creating these box plots which are
giving us values now what I can also do
is I could look at the day wise also but
before we look into this how do I infer
some information from these box plots
which are being created so this is what
we have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me ear seasonality which we were seeing
in our gear plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in Winters and
lower in summer so we can obviously look
at our plot we can see where it is lower
where it is higher and then we can look
at the median and lower two quartiles
are lower in December and January
compared to November and February so
that is you look at the quartiles and
you will see that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in December and January
kill Jan and December so you can look it
from my plot now this is giving you some
idea on seasonality
now that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at your solar and wind
power production both will give you a
year seasonality what we are seeing here
and
if basically I look at the data so it
depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise so here let me again reset
this to one plot per graph now I'll say
box plot I'll say consumption which is
group based on day now we know that
there is a day column and let's give a y
limit and let's look at the data so this
is where I am grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here I have given day and I have chosen
all the 31 days but I can break it down
to a week and I can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption where I'm doing
a consumption group by day is higher on
weekdays than on weekends
so time series with strong seasonality
can often be represented with models
that can decompose signal into
seasonality and long Trend now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here we have
looked at data so what we will do is we
look at the frequency now when you look
at the frequency when you talk about
frequency in your data so we have the
modified date column which gives me a
frequency and if we really look into the
data that will tell me that the data is
on a daily basis so for that let's look
at my data 3 again which gives me data
and you can just see all the data's data
or dates are in sequence so your 22 20
24 25 26 and so on I can look at I can
access a d player package
that is basically allowing me to work in
a better way now I can look at the
summary of this and for all my columns I
am seeing what is the minimum Phi number
summary date and consumption so date
does not show me anything because this
is not in a date format it is just a
factor but other things have the fine
number summary so we are looking at wind
plus solar we are looking at year and
month and day and all these columns now
what we will do is we will want to find
out the sum of each
column how many entries does it have and
we will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns so let me run this
again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have and these counts do
not include the N A values now similarly
I can find out specifically for
consumption I can find out is there any
n a value so I'm saying is Dot N A and
let's find out if there is any n a value
or missing value in consumption it says
0 okay that's good if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are n a
similarly solar similarly wind dot solar
or wind plus solar so it gives me a
count of n a values that is missing
values and also values which are not
missing so to understand frequency what
we can do is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the First Column and
I am saying RM
n a DOT RM is true that is get rid of n
a values and find out the minimum and
let's look at the minimum value this is
the minimum from my modified date
now if I would want to get the frequency
I can basically use sequence function so
I can say from X minimum that is the
minimum value I want to look at the
frequency that is day wise and let's
just look at five entries and see if
there is a day by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is day wise
frequency so that allows me to look at
the frequency look at the type of it it
is an integer class is a date so
similarly we can say from X minimum we
can basically look at the frequency
month wise and I can again look at five
records so that shows me monthly data
right so I can extract the data for
frequency similarly yearly data and
that's also very useful now we can
select data which has any values for
wind so how do I do it I would want to
find out the wind column and I want to
find out where the values are in a so I
will create a variable and here I will
say my data 3 and then I give a
conditional where I say is n a
in the column so let's do this now once
I've done this
once I have done this I have said that
my selected wind data from my data 3
where we said any values and I will give
the names to this so name should be in
my data 3 I'm interested in mod data
consumption wind and solar so these are
the four columns I'm interested in let's
look at first 10 records here or first
10 rows so that tells me these are the
values where wind has n a or missing
values
I can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data so it basically shows
me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has any solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out any values
now what we will do is we will select
data which does not have any values so I
will call it cell selected wind 2 I'll
again use my data 3 I will say which but
now I am saying not any
from this column and I will select the
data for the columns so I am interested
in looking at 10 records and this shows
me not any value so no more missing
values so if I really look at this data
as I saw earlier which has n a and if I
look at these values which are not any
for the wind column so looking at these
two result we will know that in year
2011 wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do I
do that let's call it a different
variable I'll say my data 3 I will say
here when I say which where we were
saying n a here I will say the year
should have a value of 2011 and I want
all these columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
V
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame to a view and
this one will help me in finding out
where are the N A values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and I will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
I could select and search for one
specific value and I'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data and seeing is
wind column having n a or missing value
for a particular row and let's scroll
here and here you see there is a missing
value for one particular row so 13th
December 2011 has wind value 15 December
has wind value but
your 14th December does not have right
similarly we can search so there was
only one entry which was missing now
that could be for some reason might be
it was not calculated might be it was
not tabulated so we have a missing value
and that can affect my plotting that can
affect my analysis so let's look at the
number of rows in this which will tell
me how many rows we have for 2011 so it
tells me 365 so that is basically the
number of days in a year now we will
find out if there were any values so we
earlier checked total number of any
values per column
that is in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269
so this is where we were seeing are
there any n a values right so let's go
back here
and
we want to find out the number of any
values for a particular year how do I do
it so I can just do a sum I will say is
n a now I am interested in my data 3
wind column and I am saying my ear has
to be 2011 but I am finding out the N A
values
so let's do this and it tells me one and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see how many non-na
values you have and that is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so it's 364 plus 1
missing so there are 365 let's look at
the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable
selected wind 4 I will save in 3 that is
which was having all my n a and non-na
values for 2011 I will say let's find
out the n a value
because I am interested in finding out
that particular row so I'm saying find
out where the values n a and I want all
the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific
row which has a n a value
now we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has n a and
non-na values so let's say let's call it
test one I will use wind 3 which has n a
non-na values but now I will say I want
the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001. now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of December there is no date
so I will select a subset of data which
includes this n a and non n a that is
might be I can take 13th of December and
15th of December so let's start from 12
so the date should be greater than 12 12
that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have a I've selected a
subset of data I could have done this
using subset also so I have any and non
any values now why are we doing this so
sometimes you might have some data for a
particular column and you may want to
find out if there are any missing values
might be you want to fill them up or
replace them with something so that is
usually useful when you are doing a
trend detection so say for example you
have data for every month and might be
in one one of the months you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly and then in one of the
years for a couple of months you don't
have the data like I can say 2016 I have
data for all 12 months 2017 all 12
months 2018 might be a don't have data
for March and June 2019 I don't have
data for same months so I can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous year's same month data so we
can do that so here I have test data
where I have extracted a subset of data
I can look at the class of this it is a
data frame structure of this it has the
columns now let's use the library
and function and use the Tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so I will use test one I will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward filled so filling values
can be done in different directions as I
said and you may want to First convert
your time series to specified frequency
if your data does not have a frequency
but we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as I showed you and then
basically you can do a forward fill
for the values so for example if I have
my data I can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data I
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data then let's
look at the trends of the data which is
the last part of this project so
basically let's look at the trend So
when you say Trend what does that mean
so in Time series data you always have
some kind of trend so that will exhibit
some slow gradual variability in
addition to higher frequency variability
such as seasonality and noise now to
visualize these Trends what we do is we
use what we call as rolling means so we
know how our data is spread over year or
month or day but how about looking at a
rolling average and see what is the
difference so a rolling mean will tend
to smooth a Time series by averaging out
the variations and frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called those
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame you can also average out any
seasonality on a time scale equal to
window size so this will allow you to
look at lower frequency variation in the
data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean using the
zoo package and you can say what is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I am going to my look at my data 3 which
we have been using so far now let's call
it a three day test you can give it any
name I'm going to use my data 3 I'm
using the piping function
now I will use D plier and I will
arrange the data descending in here now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so I'll call it as
says 0 3 day so I'm going to calculate a
rolling mean every three days for my
consumption column and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and here
when I'm doing a three day test
let's look at the result of this and
then I'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven is
the average consumption in 2017 from the
first date with the data point on either
side of it that is you can look at this
date so one one three zero then you look
at
you are looking at the value one three
six seven here so you look at one one
three zero one four four one one five
three zero if I take a mean of these so
for example if I would just do this part
and that
is giving me mean okay because I have a
comment so let's basically add anything
as comment and then let's do this so it
saves me one three six seven that's what
we are seeing here right so you're
getting a rolling average every three
days similarly if you want every five
days it takes the five values and it
gets the mid value right so you can
always find out the mean rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and yearly data that is 365 days so how
do I do it same logic my data test
now I am using my data 3 I'm arranging
it in a descending order I am grouping
by year so when you do a group by year
so earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had right so
let's do a grouping by year and let's
say test 0 7 so that's a rolling average
every seven days and I'm also saying
take care of the N A values similarly
I'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly might
be you can do half yearly and let's do
this so let's create this my data test
and let's look at the result of this so
I will use my data test I will say
arrange based on modified date now we
know there is a column called modified
date I want to just look at 2017 data so
I'm doing a filter
right and then I will choose what are
the columns I'm interested in so I will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first seven records so let's do
this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average or the F7
day mean which is for first seven days
and then 365 you will not see the data
here but if I do a view on this I can
basically see the values so you can
always select a particular column to see
the values
these are the values for every seven day
rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days so you see all the values
are missing but every 365 entry you will
have basically some data
now
let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting I will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is spread over a period of
time and that's fair enough but now
let's add some more plot to this so I
will add the seven day rolling average
to this so for second plot to be added
in the same one in R you can use points
so I will say points I will choose seven
data column type is line width x limit y
limit and color so let's do this and
that's my pattern seven day rolling
average which basically gives me some
kind of trend
similarly I can add one more here and
this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be
aware in x axis and y axis so I am
saying it will be 2500 and Y is 1800 so
my Legend will come in some in here I am
saying my Legend will have consumption
test and this one I can give some names
I can give what is the color I can say
what kind of
Legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
I've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here I see that my x axis is fine but Y
axis is going a little about of my
plotting area so I can actually change
that so here I have 1800 how about
making it 1600 and let's look at this
one so we can basically uh go for this
one and start again here plot and points
and line and then add a legend right and
you can basically place your Legend
anywhere in the plot so this basically
is giving me the trend what I'm looking
at my rolling average so similarly you
can look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so seven day
rolling mean has smoothed out all week
leases anality which we were seeing Here
in My Graph where you look at every
seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality so seven day will tell that
electricity consumption is typically
higher in Winter and lower in summer so
better is you break it down uh yearly so
here if you look at every year you can
see when it's winter when it's summer
what is the seasonality what your Trend
what you are seeing here and if there is
a decrease or increase for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
365 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically
uh reduces the variation so if I look at
360 by Rolling mean we can see long-term
Trend in electricity consumption is
pretty flat now that's what we are
seeing it's kind of pretty flat there is
not much variation over years if you
really join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code which you have here in the
form of a project.r file you can find
here in my GitHub page this is a
document which explains some things feel
free to download this and you can add
details to it this is the sample data
set which you can also find in my
repository in the data sets folder so
continue learning and continue
practicing r
Excel is a really powerful tool for data
analytics and Reporting and pivot tables
are one of the features that Excel
offers for creating tabular reports to
summarize our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in its spreadsheet to
obtain a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives viewer tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to The Columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displace the
summarized information the most common
values are some average minimum and
maximum finally we have filters filters
apply a calculation or restriction to
the entire table
so let's jump over to Microsoft Excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with India
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze India's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across India stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socioeconomic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first I'll show you one of the features
that Excel offers us so suppose I click
on any cell and hit Control Plus Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis now you can see
by the features such as formatting we
have charts totals and this one more
called tables now Excel by default has
created some pivot tables for us now the
first one you say is sum of district
code by state names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City
then we have the male and female
literates next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data go to the insert Tab and
here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and I'll give my location I'll point to
cell Q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table Fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what I'll
do is
I'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want the total population for each of
these states so in the field list I'll
search for total population which is
this one and drag it under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states by default
Excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
I right click go to sort option and
choose Z to A
that is largest to smallest
you can see here
in 2011 Maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in Maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
Pradesh we had Andhra Pradesh
and if I come down we have nagaland and
Andaman and nicobar Islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pivot table
my range is selected I'll choose
existing worksheet and give my location
which is Q5
I click on OK
now here we want to find the total sum
of literates so what I'll do is first
let me drag
total literates column two values you
have the total sum of literates from all
the states
next I want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then
will track City
on two rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have Bihar
and if I keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himanchal Pradesh that's
Jammu and Kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand Karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
I'll select cell Q5
and click on OK
now
since we want the average sex ratio and
the child sex ratio so first I'll drag
those columns either you can manually
scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if I look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed you can just drag it from
there let me delete this
and I also want this x ratio
so I'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is
I'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average Now by
default Excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child sex ratio so what
you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to Value field settings
and here summarize values by you can
choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of six ratio click on OK
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into average I'll again click on the
drop down
go to Value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio for each of the
states now the next question says which
states had the highest and lowest sex
ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011 Kerala had the highest sex
ratio and if I scroll down to the bottom
you can see himanchal Pradesh had the
lowest which is around 818.
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivot table you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates so let's see from the entire
pivot table how we can filter the top
three cities
so I'll go to insert click on the pivot
table option
go to existing worksheet
click on Q5
and hit OK
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag
City column onto rows and then we want
the female graduates so in the search
bar I'll look for female
and I'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values so I have the sum of
email graduates for each of the Cities
now since we want to find the highest
number of female graduates in the top
three cities so let me first short this
column
I'll sort it in descending order
we have it sorted from this you can say
that Delhi greater Mumbai and Bengaluru
are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on OK
there you go we have the required pivot
table ready and it only displays us the
top three cities with the highest number
of female graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a Slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here What's the total
population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing I'll click on a
location this time q6
click ok
now since I want the total population so
I'll drag total population onto values
and then I'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
I'll place it on top of City so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for Rajasthan and Karnataka so
I'll search for
these two so here we have Karnataka so
let me select Karnataka first
and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for Rajasthan and Karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
Karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for Rajasthan
moving ahead now we will see another
very interesting feature of pivot that
is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
I'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and I'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll drag
mail literatures onto values followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the male literacy and
female literates value
and also I want to drag
State column
two rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
I'll select any cell
and
I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select
percentage of grand total so I'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if I sort this you will get to know
which state contributed or has the
highest percentage contribution
so we have Maharashtra for male
literatures
then we had uttar Pradesh in 2011
if I come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar Islands
as two states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
I'll go to show value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh then Gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literates
so this is another good feature
to convert your data and C10 in terms of
percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well I'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on OK
now since I want to see based on States
as well as cities so let me drag the
state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
I'll drag it onto values
now we have the list of states and the
respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each City
now
first I'll
sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to the
cell
right click go to filter and select top
10.
now I'll
replace top 10 with bottom and I want
the bottom three cities from each state
I have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates if I click on OK
you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
Andaman and Uber islands has only one
city that is Port Blair while the
remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so Andhra
Pradesh had these three in Assam we had
nagao then there was dibrugar and
silchar similarly if I come down in
haryana we have palwal kathal and zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this gangavati this Rani banur
and this cooler similar you can see for
Kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example I'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in Excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items calculated fields or
formulas that can refer to other fields
in the pivot table
calculated Fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value Fields a calculated Fields
name May proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables and
those have been categorized as fruits
and vegetables we have the price per kg
and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be the
product of price per kg and quantity so
let me show you how you can do that with
the help of a pivot table
I'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit OK
now
if you see on the top under pivot table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets
if I click on this drop down I get the
option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this
I'll give my field name as sales
and
I'll select my formula
I'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
I'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol and then I'll double
click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I'll click on ADD
and I click on OK
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table or original table is the
same but here we have added a calculated
field which is present only in the pivot
table list now we can use this it has
already taken it under values
now let's say I want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here we have our category
fruit and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different items
like apple apricot banana similarly in
vegetables we have broccoli this carrots
corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivot table
now there's one more good feature that
Excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so I'll show you how to do that
if I go to insert
here I have the option of recommended
charts click on this Excel gives me some
default charts which you can use
let's say I'll select this
let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice bar chart that Excel has
created this is called a pivot chart now
here you can see the category fruits and
vegetables and the different fruits and
vegetables or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
seals if you see from the graph guava
meet the highest amount of sales now if
I sort this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my pivot table the
pivot chart also automatically gets
updated similarly there are other charts
also that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on OK
so here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents it had the highest amount of
seals in this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first I'll
click on my pivot table go to insert
and under recommended charts let's now
select a line chart
if I hit OK
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it drops
and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broccoli made the
highest amount of sales with
2800 rupees and our lowest was eggplant
at 900 rupees for fruits papaya sold the
least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
is an horizontal bar chart now you can
always increase and decrease the size of
this charts
let's explore
our last start let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the line chart it starts with
guava which had the highest amount of
sales similarly papaya under fruits had
the lowest amount of seals and the
vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant with the
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first seed and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for pivot tables in Excel so we had our
data
this is a 2011 Census Data from India we
had the different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates male
literatures we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then we saw
another preview table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each City belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the different
state names and the cities under each
state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and Bengaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates
next we saw how to use Slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
Rajasthan Karnataka State and saw the
total population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literatures from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates one thing
marked that some of the states did not
have three cities for example Andaman
had only one city that was sport player
but the others we found out the bottom
three cities that had the lowest female
graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table so we
saw
how to create a calculated field called
sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw is a column
chart we also saw or looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well in this video we'll be
creating two dashboards using a sample
sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards an
advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating our dashboards
we'll be using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo so this data set
was actually generated using a simulator
and is completely random it was not
validated though we have applied certain
transformations to the data using power
query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa there's North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can say this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online next
we have the order priority column now
here C stands for critical
then we have H which is for high
priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
I'll click on a cell in my data set and
then I'll go to the insert tab here we
have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is I'll drag my order here
column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
I want
this die
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give two commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99
000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014 it reached 195
million
and after 2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table I just click ok so
that my PO table is placed on a new
sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go
so we have our next pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the sub-Saharan African region
in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa made the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017 so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012
then in 2013
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as Revenue
by
year end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format axis
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
reduce or you can increase you can see
now it's 12 if you want you can make it
16. similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column all right so here we have
the pivot table ready now based on this
pivot table let's create our pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add data labels so I'll click
on data labels here okay so these are
the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options
if I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I'm going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this makes your sheet more readable
all right
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet and create
our pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and here you have pie
chart
I want to select this 3D type of pie
chart and I'll click on OK all right so
we have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it
and from here I'll remove the field
buttons
and also don't need the Legends I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now let's create our horizontal bar
chart I'll go to insert click on pivot
table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows
and then I'll choose total revenue and
place it under values
so here you have the different country
names you have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India this Jamaica Italy and all
the way to the bottom if we go we have
New Zealand this Netherlands Philippines
Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our po chart so I'll go to insert
and select recommended charts
from here I am going to select the
column chart you can see the preview
here and let me click on OK
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style six okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time I'm going to drag item
type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different item names and
then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so you can see
here office supplies meet the highest
amount of Revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits meet the lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time I am
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I have selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's see I want to select green color
all right
I have edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14 and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I am going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
all right
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Centerline it
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see ship format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so my text box is transparent now and
I'll also remove the outline all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
30.
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so I've also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline you see this so we have our
total revenue by year which is a line
chart and this is completely transparent
now now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box
so I'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so I'll
click on illustrations and here I'll
choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape
here I'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the axis labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add this blue background to
all the other charts so we'll first add
the background make it transparent and
then we'll convert the font text to
white color to make it more readable and
visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard so I have added a few logos
for each of the charts you can see the
logos here so for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down
you have numbers
and under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
Tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or if you go
to the pivot chart analyze tab here also
you have insert slicer and timeline
option so I'll select insert slicer here
first now it's giving me the list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region
and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values so under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slices to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to select
all the pivot tables so let me check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slices we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers
so I'll right click on this go to report
connections and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
I'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
go to report connections and then I'll
select all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and return only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
this chart represents the revenue that
was generated in each of the countries
only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channels so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
offline
if you
see here now these were all the offline
seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added different
icons then we formatted the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
now we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating our pivot tables and po
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart to visualize the profit for each
year
so I'll drag my
total profit column to values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay and if you want you
can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country name so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
I'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
in Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right now we want to create a map
out of this the way to do is
I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light gray color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can see light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this map to the
original data source so what I do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so
my new range
will be my original po table that I had
created
go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
the countries that made least amount of
profit
okay
now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales Channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column to rows
and then
I'll choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here now based on
this pivot table let me create my PO
chart so I'll go to recommended charts
and I'm going to create a line chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly
in year 2012 the Online Profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say SC for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivot
table and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here I click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's say C which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally I am going to create a report
that will show the revenue and profit by
items
so I'll go ahead and create my pivot
table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building our dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
will continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now
will insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustrations
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard so here you can see I have
brought my Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of Revenue
now we'll copy each of the charts that
we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard so
let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I've also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid line
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I am going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I'm going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
by labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
I've also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts and
I'll go to insert under insert I have
the option to create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I am going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
similarly I'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
I'll resize this and I'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
I have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is po table number 10 if
I click on OK similarly let's create or
connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so I right click go to
report connections here I'll
choose all my Pivot tables which are
based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on OK and similarly I'll connect
my timeline as well I'll go to report
connections
and I'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts I'll
go to insert click on slicer and I'll
select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017 or
suppose you want to know the profit that
was generated in the year 2012 so I'll
just click on this range and now you can
see our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
no if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
be checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer let me just bring
this to the middle and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just bring this to the front so that you
can see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item meet the highest
amount of profit in
United Kingdom now you can also select
multiple countries let's say I want to
know for France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually
not millions that should be in K that is
Thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually K and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables and
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing you can also
change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see a chart
has changed let me just delete this okay
so now once you change the theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I am going to choose
depth
and this is more
of a green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects all right
so in this demo we saw how to create a
revenue dashboard so we created line
charts this combo chart pie chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learned how to
add slicers and connected to different
pivot tables and we filtered our data to
see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
let's quickly see some more examples of
doing data analysis using Excel and for
that we can use some inbuilt add-ins
which can be added to our Excel sheet so
for example if you would want to do a
descriptive analytics or descriptive
analysis on your data say for example
getting your descriptive statistics such
as your mean median mode and so on so we
can do that and we can use Excel for it
so for example you can if you are given
some data say I have temperature price
of ice cream units sold and I would want
to have descriptive statistics on this
what I can do is I can click on file and
here in file you can click on options
and within options click on add-ins now
within add-ins you have Excel add-ins
which is selected here so click on say
go for example in that that shows what
add-ins are available and you can choose
which ones are you interested in so for
example I have chosen analysis tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature
now if I do this and I have selected The
Heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this and then you can have your
cursor blinking in here let's select
save Fields here and this is where I
would want the output now it also said
what options do you want so it has
output range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I'm
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
OK and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on OK
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically
given a value for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for data
data analysis descriptive statistics say
okay now you need to give a range so
here I will change my range to these
values output range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on OK and this says
output range will overwrite existing
data press ok to override data in range
I will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new Range
so let's select our new Range which is
here and now click on OK so now we get
the values which is for your price of
ice cream so again we can basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier I can select this I can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this B2 to B8 and this
one which is H6 to h19 we would want to
shift it might be two columns up so
maybe I can just say H5 and I can
manually change it to a 17 and let's say
okay
and we will basically get this and I can
get rid of this so I can have it in the
same range so similarly so this one will
have to be renamed and I can basically
say price of ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I am interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from H to basically something
like J so let's say J and let's select
these values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
unit sold you did not have to manually
rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistic so this is how you
can simply perform analysis using data
analysis here you can basically get your
descriptive statistics for your columns
and then you can do whatever needed
formatting you need to basically make
your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures you have
been given some pins where you would
want to identify how many values fall
into the range of 0 to 20 20 to 30 30 to
40 40 to 50 and the easiest way to do
that would be creating histogram now
histogram is usually used for data
analysis where you would want to look at
different variables or say features for
example temperature is one such feature
might be there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see if the
increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find the relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to First do analysis on one single
variable look at the frequency of values
might we also look at the defects and
for which we can use something like
Pareto chart so we can go for histogram
and that basically gives us the
frequency of values now how do we do
that so we have already added the